[Music]
[Applause]
I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet d value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters
look I
[Music]
become episode is this Rob so episode
334 guys you know years ago I don't know
what it was years years ago years this
this guy what's his name Justin
Timberlake did a song dedicated to a guy
that happens to be the guest today it's
called bring sexy back so he is back
well I did not back on the podcast you
got to have it to bring it back you got
to have it to bring it back it's good so
you have not been in this room though we
did a last time in the other place no I
just got a tour of the emerging Empire
uh here and let me tell you this is an
impressive situation you have going I
don't think people really appreciate how
much uh you guys have going in the
kitchen oh there's a situation in there
Cass the kitchen I mean there is a lot
going on with value tainment uh very
very impressive I appreciate that yeah
and you are one of my favorite content
creators I appreciate that and not
because you smell like I want to eat
right now Bak
appreciate you just saw one that's going
to come out today but you saw the trans
I am trans everything yes I appreciate
that thank you that's your favorite one
and the gift is obviously I mean you
know this you know you're you're in the
you're comic um timing the timing is so
100% good for you thank you bro I
appreciate it Chris um what do you got
come on I want
all SE I want all the smoke lots of
stuff to go through I think the first
thing I probably want to get into let me
just give you the stories so the
audience knows and then maybe we'll go
into the sponsors and then we'll do some
of the stories Charlie mman he rest in
peace 99 uh Legend you know he's uh if
you've never read the book The Charlie
Munger Almanac poor Charlie's Alma it's
a must read on any uh uh Library office
you have to read it the wisdom he shares
and they interview his kids phenomenal
guy may he rest in peace uh few stories
here so one Adams Adams plays down talk
of a Cuomo mayoral run there's this guy
named Andrew Cuomo that may run and he's
kind of talking a little bit so
we'll talk about him here in a minute
President Biden New York city mayor did
you just say my brother's talking
your brother has a way of talking yeah
he did I like I like the want to make I
did say that just I'm glad you qualified
it I want to remember why remember why
New York City Eric Adams hasn't spoken
to the president uh in a year as new
your migrant crisis worsens I I think
those two should probably talk over 200
cops have quit the job in the blue City
just this year we'll talk about that
Rona McDaniel R McDaniel brushes off
donor concerns there's nothing unusual
about this Koch Network endorses Nikki
Haley big deal for president as it looks
to stop Trump Romney says most Democrats
would be an upgrade from Trump I
definitely want to talk about that guy
Justin Trudeau sweetheart of a guy
blames Mega for turning Canadians
against Ukraine okay Dustin Trump hints
at expanded role for the military within
the US a legacy law gives him few guard
rails DeNiro says Apple Gotham Awards
cut his anti-trump speech how dare they
do that okay this is a USA Today story
and then China plans to mass-produce
humanoid robots in two years here's how
experts think the Tech Will Change the
World by 2035 China athletes as young as
7 years old in a military training to
create an iron Army 7 years old did he
temporarily steps down as chairman of
Revolt uh after being sued Americans
under 30 don't trust religion or
anything else voters the American dream
fading a new poll says Maverick owner
Mark Cuban sells majority stake to
billionaire Miriam Adon uh will retain
control of team now here's one of the
clips I do want to show before we get
Rob can you pull up this clip by his
brother your
brother I love what he says here this
was a couple weeks ago and a couple
weeks was it three weeks ago and it's
such common sense when this was
happening and I don't know if blue
States understand this concept I don't
know if Newsome understands this concept
I don't know if Illinois understands
this concept I don't know if New York
understands this concept but I want to
get your Insight and feedback on what
your brother said here 3 weeks ago go
ahead and play this people are more
mobile they will leave how do we know
that because they are leaving they have
left the people who are the most mobile
are the people with
wealth uh and we have seen wealthy New
Yorkers
leave the problem is the wealthy New
Yorkers are the New Yorkers who pay the
taxes uh
overwhelmingly when you look at where
the revenue comes from in New York it is
paid by wealthy New Yorkers over 90% of
the revenue comes from wealthy New
Yorkers so when the wealth
leaves it has a dramatic economic impact
and this is how cities historically have
gotten into trouble you lose the wealth
you lose the revenue you have less
Revenue to provide services quality of
life deteriorates because there are
fewer Services more people leave right
that's the down spiral 100% okay so when
you hear this and then you know I'm from
California okay so a lot of people left
California they went to Texas some of
them leave to Nevada they don't
necessarily come to Florida I went to
Texas then came here New York comes to
Florida or they go to
Nashville why do you think blue states
don't understand this basic logical
argument that your brother just made why
do you think blue states don't
understand it why do you think no I'm
asking why do you think I don't know
that they don't understand it you think
they understand it well I don't know how
to a portion understanding like do you
mean like the governors in blue states
don't seem to talk the way Andrew is no
no no no why why do blue States not
understand that you pushing your
business owners out hurts the economy
cost you jobs and they're going to go
somewhere else it's kind of like this if
you got somebody that's a hard worker
working for a company right they show up
early they leave late they go above and
beyond if they give you a deadline they
hit it they hit their bonuses they hit
everything they got great attitudes team
players working in every possible way
they're great you don't think there's a
hundred other people that would love to
hire this guy to this girl to go to
their company why would you not want to
keep that person in your state blue
States the last three years have lost a
lot of these types of people do they
know it when they're doing this is it
knowingly you know what's their process
when they're CU your brother again your
brother's a Democrat right and he's
saying this as a guy that's a two-term
governor himself well two things one it
shows you why labels are very limiting
right Andrew is a Democrat well what
does that mean it only means what you
hear coming out of him and and what he
does right Andrew is different than most
people in politics in one way that
should really matter to you okay he is
all about doing okay what politicians
are known for Andrew can do but it is
not his passion the Patrick B David nice
to meet you whatever you need I'll take
care of that and what what is your
concern yes I share it and here's why
and and the yap yap yap where in your
head you're saying all right the
discount effect of what this guy is
saying to what he's going to do is
probably somewhere around 70 to 80%
Andrew is the opposite of that Andrew is
yeah yeah yeah I get it I can fix it I
can fix I'll be straight about it here's
why I'm going to break a lot of
furniture I'm going to make a lot of
enemies because we're not in the
business of doing that's the way to look
at it you would never let those people
these types of entities this type of
Revenue base leave why because you're an
entrepreneur because you see the value
but you're also not in the game what I
would see is not wow what incredible
ignorance this is that these states blue
states red States whatever you want to
look at act this way I think the lens
has to be you got to think the way they
think which is not my bottom line which
is not my results it's Advantage and
what gives the people in power the best
ability to say whoever you want to
replace them with is worse it's the
opposite of your life model you don't
build value tment by saying well you
should come and do business with us
because you know the other guys PWC
they're worse Nobody Does that politics
they do you want to run against Andrew
you don't say I have better ideas you
say his or Worse he's dangerous he's bad
that's what politics is and that's how
you get these Dynamics
that don't make sense to businessman so
so I'm I'm not you're you're not in the
game strong right CU you don't even know
half of what I said you smell amazing I
want you know but so so I like Andrew
okay I like Andrew I like Andrew but but
that's good I think we you you love
Andrew I don't yet know Andrew I just
like Andrew so but for me when I see
that I'm like okay so why why did they
you know have to get rid of them why did
they pick on on him because the feeling
I get with an Andrew is Andrew is not
the type of guy the Democratic party to
me is is a bit more unified and darker
than the Republican Party my
understanding push back as much as you
want I enjoy this
so my understanding is a guy like Andrew
behind closed doors if a Schumer or a
Pelosi or even an Obama comes in and
says hey you got to step aside you got
to do this you got to have your
messaging this you got to do that you
got to be a part of the team you got to
take one for the team I don't know if
he's that guy okay I just don't know if
he's that guy I think toi goes down to
whatever your father taught you guys
those values like dude it's my father
over you bro who were you to tell me to
do this I'm my loyalty is my to my
last name my family my lineage my
Heritage what I'm it's not to you right
that's my understanding is of how his
wiring is so that means a guy like your
brother The Establishment Democrats
going to hate they're not going to like
him they're not going to sit there and
say let's work with this guy and by the
way even mayor Adams when he won and oh
he's going to be this a former cop and
then all of a sudden he's making a
couple good arguments hey uh sexual
assault from 1993 and oh right after he
disagreed with you want to drop this how
come you didn't drop it ear you mean to
tell me you didn't know about this well
no it's because the New York laws
changed all I'm saying is there's two
two arguments you made I'll bring one of
them back afterwards but the one area is
is there a pattern of the establishment
Democrat not liking guys like your
brother or mayor Adams I think in the
party system you know you can debate the
you talk to a bunch of Democrats they'll
say the GOP is cohesive they're a pack
animal uh Trump has cemented that
ideology that mentality whereas the
Democrats are like hurting a bunch of
cats and they don't Galvanize that's why
you don't see uh media um uh media
Outlets that are as left dedicated as
you see on the right in these cottage
industries because they're not as
cohesive a group but that's neither here
nor there in the Party politics game
okay there is a weird there's a paradox
at play okay which is the idea of
stronger Robert Downey Jr probably wants
to say hello to you hold on yeah let's
get him on he's the best I got to tell
him a tradition he needs to know I'm in
a bank vault right now but look we're
shooting the podcast look who it is
Robert can I tell you something I didn't
tell you last time it actually is Robert
dowy J on the phone Robert how you doing
hang on let me take you off this just
give him the volume never had a never
had a better
day up I'm the hor you're freaking
amazing funny Robert I got to tell you
do you know what our tradition is every
Christmas when we we're with the family
you know what movie we watch every
Christmas watch out I'll kill
you the only movie in my life that I
watched backto back on a flight back
from Europe was the judge
it's the only movie I've ever watched
back to back in my life only and every
Christmas with the family I swear to God
every Christmas with the family we sit
there and we watch the judge Tom you
were there we watch the judge together
every Christmas we sit down and we watch
that what a freaking amazing movie man
you're you're one of a kind we love you
uh big fans of your work
brother thank you happy holidays to
everyone and I love the the Synergy that
happens
differents come together I get the
picture God
bless Le God
bless Brothers I love you brother I'll
call you right after this please all
right thanks Robert take care take care
take care did the Iron Man just called
yeah let me tell this is what happens
when Chris Chromo shows up Robert Dy Jr
just pops let me tell you something that
guy is not only the easy part is he is a
defining actor of the generation right I
mean he his ability to do different
things his personal story his commitment
to change the friend that he has been to
me has never asked me for a thing um he
is one of the most special people you
could be lucky enough to have in your
life and he's one of those people where
you'll never know it he's never going to
celebrate himself he's not one of those
celebrities where you know he has like
these you know these kind of carnivals
around him so you know how great he is
MH uh this I I talk to him every chance
I get he's a straight up guy how did you
guys become so close Co during this is
relatively new during Co he like didn't
believe that I could be in this cycle of
being this sick and doing TV and then
like flop sweating for the next 11 hours
so he gets my number he's Robert Downey
Jr he's going to get your number if he
wants your number right so we text I
said oh you know big fan um I had met
him a couple of times years earlier and
he said uh you know how's it going
brother I said well right now pretty
shitty you know because I got aund and
something fever and he's said can we
FaceTime I said sure So he facetimes me
and I'm like sitting in the sauna trying
to sweat because I would try to sweat as
much as I could take a really cold
shower you know you know hold the whole
cycle of trying to stop the fever and we
started talking about what matters in
life and he's an extraordinary guy I
have never met I haven't met a lot of
people like him full stop in that
business I've never met anyone like him
the guy the guy's depth is phenomenal I
he gives me the Vibes of a guy that I'd
love to have dinner with just have
conversations with if you don't like him
there's something wrong with you he's
one of those he gives me that feeling
you don't like me there's good reasons
him there's something wrong with you
you're very likable behind the scenes
I've been talking about you've been
talking about Robert Downey Jr for years
prior to even Cuomo bringing him up you
made us all watch the movie the judge
but even prior to that oh I I made you
guys watch it to explain how emotional
that movie was there so many different
scenes of it but let me go back to your
brother okay let's not digress let me go
back to your brother so to me the
feeling I get from the Democratic
establishment they cannot stand people
like your brother see I think it's a
party thing now look I I'm not telling
you anything you guys uh haven't known
and read for a long time Andrew is not
in the business of making friends when
it comes to politics why a little bit of
it is what he saw in Our Father who was
all about the people who put him there
because he had only been rejected by the
institution yeah you know pop was not
considered uh what I am a privileged
white male he was seen as an ethnic and
he was kept down he was other he was
poor he was new uh he was Gap toothed uh
you know Mercurial Mario all these like
little code words for being an Italian
SL mafosi type so that's Andrew's DNA
right but then within the system they're
never going to take care of an Andrew
he's too powerful he he's too Dynamic
he's too much of a threat that's the
nature of Party politics it's not unique
to Democrats um and you have to know how
to play the game and the higher you get
obviously the more risk there is the
idea though that I would push back on a
little bit is they came at him look the
game has rules okay and on the
Democratic side an allegation is enough
one okay you get Chris stop it listen
I'm telling you they have that's their
rule that's their rule look at Al
Franken you get look and they Minnesota
you're saying yeah they can have their
rules so when it's guilty until proven
innocent that's how it works in the
Democratic party this seems tical to
American values it's about believing the
people who make the accusation it's
about having the right um goal which is
equity fairness uh but what happens if
you go too far with it and you make it
political we're watching it in real time
but Andrew put himself in a position
where he was vulnerable and they came
after him now was there something about
that that was partisan in nature of
course it's politics MH and is it
painful for me 100% you know I don't
like anything about what happened but I
understand it and you know the the risk
for Andrew is cuz look he's got P public
service in his bones like I would like
for him so much to get into business
with Pat and he's so smart he's so
entrepreneurial he understands so many
different things he has so much reach
and contacts I would love him to live a
good easier life where he's making money
he's creating value for people enough of
having people try to find ways to bring
you down 247 365 he disagrees he he
doesn't believe that that is a
purpose-driven life for him personally
now what that means he's friends with
mayor Adams mayor Adams reached out to
him when a lot of other guys didn't
Andrew is not going around trying to
become mayor of New York City um if
something happens to the mayor well then
things change but that's not a fair
analysis you know what I mean the New
York Post says Andrew CUA wants to run
for you know they might as well say he's
got three heads they got as good a
chance as being Chris do you believe in
the this random but do you believe in
the Deep State um not the way you guys
do I believe that bureaucracies are
dangerous and entrenched power without
accountability gets dangerous I don't
see the Dynamics the way other people do
like I don't believe the doj is
operating on a set of political
guidelines that are given by anybody in
any current Mo moment and look Eric
Adams is proof of that they come up to
to the guy at a public event and ask for
his phones you better have something on
that guy if you're going to do that to
him and I know the probable cause
standard for a warrant but there's a way
to do the job you come up to a guy who's
a mayor of New York City at a public
event and say we want your devices you
don't think that everybody's going to
see it you're doing it because
everybody's going to see it so they
better have something and they better
have something soon especially where we
are in a culture right now where
everybody is dubious about whether or
not the administration of justice is on
the level and I think they but it does
show you that it's not just right left
he's a Democrat here's here's a thing on
what you're saying with the left just
the first 30 seconds you you know this
one's two minutes I don't want it's the
part when he says you give them an inch
it's the one minute video because this
is you can press play and we'll find it
with this one this is the new leader of
Argentine
uh amazing Hair by the
way
for
there you
go
stop at this point so I by the way this
isn't just America the left is like that
worldwide it's not anything new the the
and and by the way my mic I don't know
if you guys can hear me or not okay as
long as you can I can't hear myself your
words are echoing in my head okay good
so so to and by the way you know when I
read that and I hear that I visualize a
meeting behind closed doors you you you
know I'm not asking you to yeah there
was a meeting I visualized there being
been a meeting behind closed door where
your brother said f off and then they
said oh really okay mother you know
we're going to show you who you're
dealing with here and we're going to
come after you and they they went from
one minute wanting him to be president 6
months later they're destroying him
tarnishing him I'm sorry I don't know
you got to be careful about who the they
is the left establishment Andrew I see I
don't believe in the monolithic nature
of it um in within New York which is
where Andrew is operating which has its
own political Machinery especially on
the Democrat side right it's
prohibitively Democrat um it depends
where you are you know very
interestingly even Andrew who set all
these records for winning elections 62
counties in New York he doesn't win all
the counties you he wins the population
centers uh like most of the states even
blue states there is uh a lot of red
within the blue it's just within the
population centers it's all blue but by
county by county and that's what we see
in the country that place by place you
have a lot of people who are on the
right it's just not in the big
population centers within New York
Andrew uh was the big dog okay and he
was therefore a Target but I don't think
it's as simple and look I'm his brother
I'd love it to be exactly what you're
saying saying but I don't think it is uh
he put himself into a position where he
was vulnerable uh was that position
orchestrated was it Amplified was it
used to hurt him yes yes and yes uh but
the situation still existed and if he
decides to run again he's going to have
to figure out where he fits in that game
because you got to have a team you
cannot run who's going to back him up
you I don't know but you you can't run
as somebody outside like this Bobby
Kennedy stuff I believe Bobby Kennedy Jr
you know people are selling an idea of
what's possible in the American
electorate that I've never seen
manifested it'd be nice if somebody
could just come in with populous
sentiment and break through the
Machinery I don't even know how he's
going to get in a ballot on all the
states because of this the party
Machinery you got to look at the parties
Patrick and you got to be
careful about wanting to see them as
being so different I could make the same
argument as the head of Argentina about
the far right and I think one of our
problems is you look at what's happening
with this Pro Palestine movement on on
the far left and then you have reaction
formation on the far right where they
come up with a bill to kick Palestinians
out of the country why how did that
happen because everything has to be
binary and once the left goes too far in
a direction you know the right is going
to do something why because it's all
about competitive Advantage between the
two of them and as long as we have that
system we'll never get the way you live
your life we'll never get to the models
of efficiencies output values expect
you'll never get to it because as long
as it's either me or him the guy who
wins this is the one who makes the other
one look worse if he and I are in a
competition that's not quantitative
right it's a running race it's a push-up
whatever it is what is my better chance
of getting your um your preference
here's why you should like me I want to
do this this and this what do you
think's easier me saying that or me
saying did you hear what he did to that
puppy did you hear what he did to that
puppy did you did you see when his
mother was trying to enter traffic and
he like walk behind her she could have
gotten hit by a car all of a sudden
you're like yeah the hell's wrong with
this guy that's what decides our
elections and this guy as a leader is
doing something that's very effective
he's giving you someone to fear he's
giving you someone to blame for what you
don't like and he's making it Us and
Them this is the classic Model of
demography but he's right to you he's
right no no but he is right though it's
to you he's right they can say the same
thing about the far brother if you say
it to me it's right no it's called Data
150% inflation 80% inflation it's not to
me it's right there you know like that
that concept where the left and the
right do and they said to you it's right
to you it's right I want to know what is
right I go based on results so when when
but you want to do inflation then then
do it you understand the economics very
well you dumped a bunch of money into
the system yeah right not just the
quantitative easing one two and three
but then everything during the pandemic
inflation was on its way and you
turbocharged it and it was going to
happen now to blame it on Biden in this
word Biden nomics I don't even know what
it means or to even just blame it on
trump it was coming and you fed it
that's not a right left problem that's a
that's a you know that's a plus minus
but inflation in Argentina is as
skyrocketed it's not even comparable
what's going on the problem in Argentina
is a kleptocracy it's about corruption
all right now if he wants to come in and
say I'm not going we're not going to
have corruption anymore um and let's
look at the people he puts around him
let's look at the deals that the
government does and if he lives to that
then great and hopefully the people
reward him for that but that's what it
is it's not just that the left loves
inflation and the right loves fiscal uh
you know conservativism look what
happened during the Trump Administration
they spent like crazy they had tax cuts
that didn't pay for themselves why
because you spend the money when you're
in power why cuz that's how you stay in
power and then when you're the out party
you say the other side spend too much
because it's always about showing the
other side is worse it's the problem
with
binary and I get it that it seems like
it's a defense of the left why would I
be defending the left after what I've
seen in my own family why if I'm saying
it it's because I mean it and I'll tell
you what my I say all the time all I
want from people in elections leave the
parties I know it's going to screw you
in primaries I know I know that has to
change but that won't change until this
changes you have to leave the parties
now people will crush me the especially
the Democrats how can you draw this
false equivalency this is so dangerous
it's always been dangerous somebody is
always dangerous I've grown up in this
business my father was a danger can't
have an angry ethnic in there who knows
what kind of Retribution he wants you
know what is this it's always been that
the other side's dangerous why it's a
cheap way of saying I can't make the
case that I'm better that's where where
danger comes from that's where beware
comes from and it is the fruit of the
poisonous tree of a two-party system
leave the parties the way George
Washington told us to the way James
Monroe the way Teddy Roosevelt FDR leave
the parties get rid of them be a nation
fight it out let the best ideas win get
away from the factions that is the only
salvation for us Pastor you'll never get
there with two teams I want to sit there
and believe you and agree with you but
it's very hard because when feel like
you were believing Because by the way
before before we get into that Rob why
don't we go to our sponsor real quick
we'll come back to this go forward yeah
you need to wait so look I've been in
the financial industry since 9911 the
day before 911 and I've owned stocks
bonds mutual funds real estate crypto
gold you name it I've owned it but the
one thing that's very important part of
my portfolio all these years is gold I
love having a percentage of my network
in Gold that I have access to in case of
many different things that's why we
chose to work with our new sponsor
American hardford Gold if you have
retirement funds that you cannot afford
to lose American Harford gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American Harford gold a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on the link in the
description or call 866939 6984 again
6984 okay so
um I want to believe you I want to sit
there and say okay well look at this way
let's say I'm I'm wrong that's fine why
would I be lying let's play on that I
don't think it's lying I don't I don't
say lying is it delusion no no I I think
it's it's loyalty I think it's I have no
loyalty to a political party zero but to
me like you almost have to because of
your father because your father was a
great man and he was a great father so
loal loyalty to the party they were mad
at him when he left because of what he
did with the campaign money and that he
didn't want to just dump it back into
the state party that he wanted to make
choices about where that campaign fund
could go he was an outsider he was an
Insurgent he was rejected he lost
election after election after election
we are not a party family that is not
this is not the have a bit of a a
naivity in you are you like a little
naive like are you a little naive or I
have lived this the way you have lived
hair styling you understand I have been
living this my whole life there car's no
I mean you got a nice qua let's be
honest but there is no chance that I am
not seeing it for what it is I just
think it's actually a Step Beyond that
which
is people are not allowed to process it
this way you have to see one side as
worse and you have to pick a side and
that is the game and we're just caught
in it I work in it but I see it I see it
you want to talk about what happens on
the right what happens on the left I see
it as the code in The Matrix about who's
playing to Advantage right now you don't
think this guy's singing from the Trump
Song Book for a reason now I think he
does it uh in a more extreme and
outrageous fashion maybe it's going to
work for I don't know um but we know the
populist outrage handbook you know
before trump it was uh Tom tang kredo
and all those guys on the gop's right
culture Fringe um we know the book
you're GNA see it on the left why it
works the only thing that hasn't changed
yet look here proof of
premise the population that loves Trump
right now we Democrats a generation
ago a republican when I was growing up
always looked like that always dressed
like this suit and TI now they're all
Democrats the wealthiest people are all
Democrats the wealthiest people used to
be the Republicans and the workers the
unions the emerging
class the ugly masses they were the
Democrats now it's flipped why
outrage the outrage pendulum swung and
now you have it the other way where you
have white people not just white but a
lot of white in a country that's over
half white feeling that culturally
they're being marginalized and for bad
reason not for the reasons of diversity
and shared strength but to marginalize
them I get messages all the time you
notice how there are fewer white people
in commercials now now the answer is no
no I don't measure that kind of thing
but this person is and why because they
see it as proof of this people saying I
don't think my kid can get into school
anymore and someone can argue it oh but
but by percentage they're wrong
perception is reality in politics people
are afraid they feel that things can't
be trusted can't be managed and are not
in their favor and it's on purpose
that's what swung and I don't know how
the Democrats get it back especially
with President Biden not being able to
muscularly make a case that's any better
than what I'm saying right now um but
that's the difference the reason former
president Trump has a shot the reason
Nikki Haley has a shot is that if you
tap into grievance in a culture that is
addicted to a grievance cycle I mean
even the Middle East you know these
people are just jumping into this issue
now with none of the cultural
understanding that you have or the the
research or the the history of the
dynamic they're just jumping in and you
got all these people on the far left who
have this Affinity with oppression that
they don't even own they don't even live
they haven't even visited but it's so
real for them I don't know what the left
is going to do with that I don't know
how Biden or anybody who runs can deal
with that you know they thought BLM was
a problem BLM had a contextual relevance
in a social Dynamic that's going on here
right now you now have an aspect of your
party in a significant aspect saying
terrorism terrorism you know Hamas
terrorists really we've never heard that
in America before never never the only
minority that's allowed to be
discriminated against in America is
Jewish people where did this come from
why is it manifesting on the left so
many Democrats are left grievance it's
about the pendulum of grievance and that
is the beginning of the swing back of
the grievance pendulum
why why would it be swinging back the
problems still exist maybe they're even
worse maybe they're more entrenched
because the right has been increasing
its power so what happens when you
increase the power you lose the outrage
because you're now you had a term with
Trump you have Republicans in power now
now you have the Speaker of the House
the pendulum starts to swing because you
can't really be pissed off about what
they are doing to you when you are the
they and now the pendulum starts to
swing we see it with this issue we'll
see it with whatever happens next p
whatever happens next you're going to
see this extreme split where we will be
uh taken hostage by the fringes again
and your
audience which is why I love coming and
being with you guys your audience are
looking at it
like who are these people where is this
coming from what is this country these
people are crazy this is all crazy and
they're the
majority and that is the hope that is
the Salvation that's why I'm such a big
fan of yours is that I believe that you
are speaking to and for and with the
regular people they got different
opinions they don't agree with
everything that you say or with each
other says that's okay that's good we
don't want group think but they're
looking at what's happening at the
people inow and they don't recognize
them they don't recognize the dialogue
they don't recognize the game they just
don't know how to get out of it so it
makes me think about three things one it
makes me think about you know um the the
psychological marketing storytelling
connecting uh campaign better story
better all okay fine that's one used to
be now it's making the other guy seem
dangerous James Carville said on my show
yesterday something I let him get away
with it's been bothering me for about 24
hours that in my right knee um he's
talking about Bobby Kennedy Jr and why
Bobby Kennedy Jr popped in the polls
these these recent uh Harvard uh Curry
polls Y and he says well people don't
even know him yet they don't know
anything about him they just like him
because of his name we haven't seen his
health records his mental health records
and and I just kind of Let It Go and I
was thinking to myself the was that
that he just said and then it registered
but he had moved on I had to catch up
with the conversation oh he's taking
Bobby de this is his way of undercutting
Bobby Ken why would you look at a guy
who takes his shirt off he looks like
you what do I need to see his health
records for you know I mean clearly the
dude's healthy wait mental health record
oh you're talking about his history of
addiction and you are putting that out
there for people that's the game but
that that's what I say to you I think I
think the gamesmanship the marketing
that whoever's got the better on that
side you know power to them but the
other thing then there is the actual
policies okay actual policies that
produce results that makes a nation a
great nation who has the better policies
that's the second one and then the third
one the sound you're going to hear is me
poppinga go for do it go for it and and
the third one Brain on Fire right I
don't want any caffeine is there
caffeine in here Zero caffeine I don't
want any sugar is there any sugar in
here Sugar N no sugar so you're good now
I saw someone drink this and they Dro
dead is that something interview coming
up that Vinnie did with Hillary we'll
drop today but and then the third one to
me is more about all right I'm okay the
third one to me is more about uh who has
more control of bigger institutions to
brainwash and inject their beliefs on
people there is no way the left has a
monopoly would say I wouldn't say
brainwash I would say influence and it's
not semantics what's the difference
here's the difference one is that uh
this is a uh a toxic Dynamic that you
are an unwilling participant in that you
don't even know that you've been duped
the other one is who's inow and what
they want and how that is reflected in
the composition and the execution of the
agencies right and that's real okay uh
you will never convince me that the FBI
is a lefty organization you don't you
really don't think that I've been
working with them you know until Trump
the media was in the business of
attacking the FBI with the we can
neither confirm nor deny and everything
takes forever and they never close a
case and they never tell you anything
and um we would work against them why
because that's the job of the media is
to test power now because of trump
attacking institutions he like put us in
a position where we had to like defend
these institutions um which was perverse
and uncomfortable but clever good good
move by him uh as was personalizing his
critic base very smart for him to
personalize the media because nobody in
the media wants to take on a president
of the United States you know maybe for
a moment just to get some shine and
pretend that you're something J Masta he
made J Masta started it you know that he
was the fake news but I mean you look
you could see him Megan Kelly I mean you
know you get a moment there Dan Rather
got it way back in the day but let me
tell you long term bad thing because
Trump's going to have a lot more
supporters than you ever will in the
media anyway um you know you see that
that is a very smart thing to do the
institution itself the FBI you're never
going to convince me guy for guy they
tend to break center right but I don't
care I don't think it influences their
job what I'm saying is not
brainwash but that when you're inow you
get the poll especially on the
Congressional side we spent years of
people on the right not being wrong when
they said God damn you go after Trump
for everything every single thing these
guys can get on and they're doing it's
like wow and now you do the same thing
when you get in why because it works and
that's the dynamic of the game so so so
Chris and let's just say looking from
the outside if you weren't even from
here and you saw just from the history
of the FBI from way back when to just
Russia collusion okay we were all duped
Hillary went you know paid for paid for
the dossier quot uh Comey all these
people and now with Christopher Ray it's
like they have a history of just lying
and then when you ask like for instance
the January 6 uh I forgot which which
Senator Congressman just questioned
Christopher Ray again and he goes can
you ple tell us how many confidential
human sources were dressed as Trump
supporters that were inside the capital
inside the capital before the doors were
open can you please tell us and he goes
I have to be careful with what I say the
answer should have been no but they they
they keep playing this game of we can't
say because there's an investigation we
can't say this for from me Chris I I
don't see how you can say that you don't
see that especially the FBI is corrupted
and they're leaning a certain way look
at what they're doing going after all
the January 6 people at their houses
they're going after mother going they're
going after the to the degree that they
go after okay that's where we get into
your territory but where you can be
pissed off about it or see it as
overreach you break into the US capital
there is Absolut absolutely no proof
that it was an orchestrated event by
confidential informant uh this happened
do I think it was an Insurrection no
okay by definition it was not an
Insurrection and it was not an act of
Terror but it was a really ugly
reflection of where we are and I can get
that people are going to be prosecuted
for it uh should the degree of that
prosecution and the punishment you can
argue that part but your main point
Christopher Ray yeah is a lifelong
Republican
as is Bob Mueller when Trump put Ray in
he loved his ass the idea that he then
all of a sudden transformed into this
Manchurian Candidate who is there to
undercut the right is nonsense now does
he give double speak and deal with
things that he should answer straight
and doesn't and does that fuel your
misgivings yes yes and yes so I'm with
you I'm with you um do I believe January
6 was a setup no I don't believe it
was set up I also don't believe it was
an Insurrection I believe it was
exaggerated in terms of why it happened
and what actually happened because
people were scared and they could play
to Advantage the same way happened with
the BLM riots right I'm one of the tools
of this Chris Cuomo said where in the
constitution does it say that protests
are supposed to be peaceful uh right in
the first line of the First Amendment
obviously I know that what was I saying
is that when people were saying who are
all these black people and their allies
shouting at the cops go home I was
making the point hey look this is
protest protest isn't going to be nice
people are going to be saying things
that are angry and hostile they're
outraged we need this in a democracy
It's upsetting but we need it I wasn't
saying that you're not allowed to
peacefully assemble maybe I'm a shitty
lawyer but I know what the First
Amendment says but why would people
twist my point that's the game why would
people twist what Ray says or doesn't
say that's the game and I just don't
know where it gets us and I I don't want
to I don't want to sit on it just really
fast with January 6 I don't want to beat
a dead horse but how then what do you
say Chris when the ex-chief of police
Steven Sun said by the way this guy is
the most trusted guy you can't just all
of a sudden Pelosi on them try to make
him look like he was full of that
guy has top secret clearance take at his
work he's a G right Chris he said they
had warnings that people were going to
be violent there was threats to life so
to not give him the resources that he
wanted to hold on a mistake why though I
I want to go deeper to go why why would
you turn down his call for the National
Guard why did he have to wait it took 71
minutes for the National Guard to show
up the New Jersey State Police showed up
before the National Guard which was four
hours so that to me with the FBI having
people in there agitating like Ray UPS
because listen Chris say what you want
inciting a riot was Ray EPS 100% he was
telling people to go in he started it he
was there at the breach he got a
misdemeanor Chris meanwhile the guy from
The Proud boys who was home got 20 years
that's where people that's the
questioning that we don't get no answers
you knew it was going to happen it
looked like they turned their back they
let it happen they went hey Insurrection
Insurrection this is a threat to
democracy it's all and it's
playing out but there's people doing 20
years for not even being there that's
where that's where I draw that line of
they knew was going to happen and let it
happen to make it look like it was
bigger look that's the truth how you
feel about the sentence of The Proud boy
guy you're you're free to feel that way
it's certainly a very harsh sentence um
and him being there not being there
obviously what he was convicted of as a
planning role but when you up you
create opportunity for people to decide
why you up and what the up
means um let's not forget that even in
this point of transition um Trump was
still the person who had populated all
of the different agencies and places of
power so it's not like everybody in
there was set up to be against them
there hadn't even been a transition yet
but when you screw up and they did screw
up you create Avenues of opportunity to
Define what it means and that's why it
becomes fuel for your suspicion and I'm
not saying you're wrong to be suspicious
I don't agree that January 6 was
anything than what we saw it as I also
don't exaggerate its significance it was
embarrassing yeah I think so but it's
not an Insurrection I don't want to see
everybody go to jail for the rest of the
i' never said anything different than
that but the FBI being a tool of the
left I'm just I'm not feeling it and
that's why we disagree cuz I think that
they're just that's fine Chris I'm
saying just the proof is is in the pting
of what we're seeing when they were when
they when they like for instance with uh
Comey with um Hillary's exoneration when
he's when they changed when she was
getting in trouble for the email the way
I see it and it's not a left right thing
okay Comey not a fan me Nei that guy
should have never involved himself in
that oh as a thing of conscience I had
to release this letter you're talking
about about the Hillary letter days
before the election screwed Hillary
Clinton with that letter you can say hey
Truth Hurts okay I'm all right with that
but the mechanism he ain't no Lefty tool
okay so same headed the same agency what
I'm saying is I don't I don't see it
that way but I certainly can judge the
actions of the people in there and you
can judge Ray um but it's not because
he's a Biden plant I mean he's Trump's
guy and uh Jim Comey thinks he was doing
the right thing only by himself
evidently because he screwed up the
whole process and the investigation
wound up not even yielding anything
satisfying back to the Russia probe what
was the problem with the Russia probe
here's the problem with all of these
things and I feel the same way about the
bidens and I feel the same way about the
trumps okay and I take a lot of heat for
this that I'm I'm disagreeing with the
idea that nobody's Above the Law and all
this first of all I believe that
nobody's Above the Law is true with a
comma why PR prosecutorial discretion
what we're talking about why does this
guy get 20 years and they bring this
kind of case and the other guy doesn't
prosecutorial discretion the law is the
law you apply it to the facts but you
make choices about who you go after and
to what extent prosecutorial discretion
Trump I don't believe it benefits what's
the ultimate thing here why do we have
Justice fairness under law why uh social
order order that's why I don't think it
helps the order I think it f fuels chaos
I think it fuels division here's my
point when you let politicians run
prosecutions of opponents you've got a
problem Congressional oversight has been
perverted into nothing but Advantage
they won't even look into their own
programs about what's flying in the air
and how they find it collect it research
it they won't tell us that but they'll
spend all this time looking into Trump's
business records um or
Biden's business r or whatever they're
looking at with Hunter Biden um I think
all of it's a mistake and all of it is a
distraction of them doing the job
they're supposed to do you do not people
put people into power to investigate
their opposition you put them in there
to make your life better not to make
somebody else's life miserable but they
don't do that anymore because they don't
need to because you'll vote for them on
this more simple basis that's easier for
them to achieve and that's my kind of
wakeup call that's my frustration of
what I'm trying to break through and I
keep getting beat down because it's hard
to go against the game can I ask you a
follow up on this cuz it's sort of
emblematic what Vinnie's asking you
about essentially what your premise is
is that this two-party system is killing
us this this binary approach to
everything that Christopher Ray is
either a righty or a lefty that's it
it's actually very nuanced Trump put him
into place but there's been a weapon
weaponization of the FBI allegedly it's
very nuanced guys Trump trump uh took
Chris Christie's recommendation for Ray
So when you say Trump put him in place
here's a guy that's coming in trusting
Chris Christie Chris Christie recommends
Ray and you can say two-party system
this isn't a two-party system issue this
is establishment anti-establishment
period deal Kennedy's were
anti-establishment they killed them
Trump is anti-establishment they've done
everything but kill them okay if you're
part of the establishment you're part of
the yes crowd you're part of the crowd
that desperately needs them you're
protected if you're not you they will
destroy your life period And by the way
we can sit here and talk talk all this
rhetoric all we want you know what's the
greatest thing about numbers is results
so meaning bad policies have
consequences why are 2500 cops quitting
their jobs in Blue City just this year I
know why okay let me read it New York
NYPD has a significant Exodus of officer
in 2023 2516 officers leaving marking
the fourth highest number in the past
decade more than a thousand officers
left before eligible for their pensions
thousand officers left before they're
eligible for their 20th year of service
the workload is a leading factor for
driving people away y from the job said
the president Patrick Henry if the NYPD
is going to survive these Staffing
reductions it cannot just keep squeezing
cops or more hours so why did they leave
these quit these jobs part of it is the
workforce issue sure but there's more
than that like what okay the job is
dangerous and these guys have been
weaponized and made into the bad guys
and by who though well largely the left
okay exactly and they feel it these are
these are men and women by the way I'm
saying largely it's not largely it's
solely the the word is it's not the
right is not the right the culture side
on the culture side yes but on the how
much do you pay them on the what kind of
protection do they get in the workforce
on the what are they up against and the
people that you're having them police
the right gets into play with its
policies and what it is against in terms
of policies but to be a cop I mean I
have a lot of my friends are on the job
and it used to be a generational thing
you know what I mean um but now it's you
they're afraid they're not going to come
home they don't get their respect
they're doing something that if you
don't see it as service you don't
understand what service is okay you're
dealing with the worst that Society has
to offer on a daily basis and God forbid
you make a move to save your own life or
that you think is right and under the
color of authority that people disagree
with you're going to get blown up and
your whole life is going and you may die
you may die if not then down the road
who wants that job it doesn't pay that
many people do many people do many
people want to be meaning when you
become a cop but I'm saying that's why
they're leaving I don't think so they
get fed up I I I think I think cops do
it for Pride I think cops do it for
protection you know how certain people
you had friends they weren't Fighters
but they were protectors meaning if
somebody said something to your smaller
friend they would fight but they
wouldn't start a fight they would have
protectors right that's the wiring of a
cop they want to protect that's a hard
job should be anyway their divorce rates
are super high it's been for decades
it's not like it's a new thing they have
very high divorce rates it's not easy
but you have to sign up for that job to
me when you sit there and you go through
numbers and you show what's going on
with numbers numbers don't like for
example we're talking about zombie
companies yesterday I don't know what we
were talking was with Beck yesterday in
Dallas we're talking about zombie
companies zombie companies in America I
don't know how familiar you are with
zombie comp we just talked this on the
last podcast so companies who were 1% of
companies in 97 were zombie companies
zombie companies are those that can only
live off of raising debt if they don't
get debt guess what they cannot survive
right today is 25% of companies are
zombie companies did you hear that
number from 1% to 25% that's the number
right there
okay over 25% us companies are zombie
companies this means the only reason
they can make it is because of low
interest rates so so what's going on
with interest rates today they're
getting crushed we had a meeting
yesterday half the conversation Tom
yesterday was about interest rates yes
or no you know what I'm talking about
absolutely and going into the impact on
Corporate America that used to you know
raise a little bit of debt to build a
factory that they could afford they
could afford the payments but now it's
mountains of debt to to pay regular cash
flow issues on regular expenses so you
know when's the first time rates went up
2017 2018 2019 rates started going back
up after the whole years of us having
low interest rates well artificially low
of course artificially
and I got to tell you you know I I'm not
disagreeing with what you're saying
you're right you're right but you know
data is very powerful uh especially as a
function of the why analysis of why the
number is what it is right the number is
only as good as its explanation let me
tell you it is frustrating for companies
to not be able to take on debt it's much
more frustrating uh for households to
not be able to take on debt and to pay
rates that would put any business
highest out rate ever on credit card
what does this have to do with the cops
though well let me make my point fair
enough so what I'm trying to say is the
fact that we can sit there and Based on
data saying the fact that this is the
reason why companies should be out and
it's not working in low interest rates
for a long time causes a lot of fake
success we don't need it we don't need
fake success there's way too much fake
success we had on over that 128 month
economic expansion 25 200 cops quitting
in New York why are you doing that
there's data this data validates the the
top two states in the country for net
positive migration this year not 2021
not 2020 not 2022 this year is Florida
number one Texas number two what is a
bottom negative uh uh net negative it's
California and New York you can spin
anything you want to spin brother any
one of us can spin it I can sit you know
when people say when you ask me like Hey
man can I talk to you yeah bro like you
know you running sales guys couple of my
guys they put on 50 pounds I'm like dude
listen man you're you're 260 PBS and
you're 5'9 that's not good for you well
you don't understand I'm big bone I have
what's the thing people say what's the
word you know no no there's there's a
thick there's a word for it like when
fat people use it as an out to say big
bon I don't know there's another one
anyways but here's the thing watch this
the reality of it is this Chris if
somebody had your routine on a daily
basis what you eat how you train what
you do you're in my house 15 minutes
you're on the floor wrestling with Dylan
and Dylan's doing Jiu-Jitsu if somebody
trained like you you think their life's
going to get better physically they're
going to get healthier yeah if they
don't get injured they but they're going
to get healthier right good practices
good results so guess what you can spin
all you want about why you're
fat results shows what the hell you eat
and how often you train and what you do
so everybody on the left can go up there
and spin up all the stuff that they want
about the right even like what the the
gentleman did yesterday with RFK well we
don't know the stuff with his mental and
all the that's spinning that's the
beautiful thing on spinning right but
but at the end of the day a guy pulls up
and finishes a conversation and says
here's the data if that's the opening
question I asked is your brother said
wealth is leaving majority of taxes
comes from wealth why are they leaving
States like New York because maybe these
policies effing suck and we have to look
at it and say we can spin and blame
Trump and blame Republicans and blame
capitalists and blame entrepreneurs and
blame everybody maybe you should blame
your policy it'd be great if that would
be the basis of the vote because one the
nice the nice comfort you have is you
happen to be right okay they're not
leaving because of the politics they're
leaving because of the reality of what's
best for them uh a little bit of that
may be a value play but most of it's
going to be an economic play right
especially as you get into more
sophisticated um uh you know class of
people that you know hey this tax
difference there's no state tax in
Florida even if I offset it with the
property tax and the sales tax I'm going
to come out 8 10 12% ahead it makes
sense
but my point you're right but that is
not the basis of play spin for that's
the least of our who cares though who
cares the voters no no no the voters but
but then it's our job no bro what you
just said right there is is you just
said you're right about the policies
yeah but we okay so then what I'm
interpreting from you is who's the last
time people voted for policy what's the
policy % I think it's 12% by the way if
we talk on abortion St it's been policy
so but that's something that's forced on
them as an issue I get that but what I'm
saying is I do think it's policies I I
also think on the other side I think one
side knows how to sell the nightmare
very well one side knows how to sell the
dream the one side that's selling the
dream has sucked at selling the dream I
had Governor Ronda santis year I'm in
the State of Florida because of him I
said sell me the dream just sell me the
dream sell me the dream why America is
the greatest country in the world
just like Bam Bam Bam that's not selling
me to dream so I agree with you that
yeah and half of his sell is how bad the
left is see that's that's the problem is
that's how he wins I don't disagree
that's how he'll win but but I don't
think he will though I don't think he
will but I'm saying if you win like
everyone's saying Nikki Haley right so
there's different layers of what she has
as an obstacle Chris Christie is pushing
her on the hey you have to deny Trump to
the no she doesn't have to deny Trump to
win what she's going to have to do is
one kill off everybody El hopefully let
let them die right I mean like something
that has to happen in the primary and
then she has to point out that the
opponent if it's let's say President
Biden is too old that's a danger he's
taking us down the way bad things are
going to happen look at the bad things
look at the far left look at what
happening there will be no if I am
president I will do this and this unless
the this and this is undoing something
that he did mhm that's the game and
she's not wrong to play it that way cuz
that's how you win but if some wants to
sell you the dream there are two things
that change a grievance uh culture cycle
one is amazing catastrophe huge crisis
that galvanizes because you don't have
any time for 911 okay now you
can argue whether or not uh we were
focused on the right things after 911
right there were all these people who
are getting brutalized and islamophobia
and I didn't like it and I was against
it but uh everybody shut up with the
right and left President Bush was
walking around in a city that he wasn't
welcoming um mayor Giuliani was dead man
walking in New York politically before
but everybody put away all those fights
many of them were artificial and really
just to suit the game not real policy
and they were only focused on policy and
what's the number one policy self-
Protection keep us safe so that's the
one thing that can do it pandemic was
not a big enough crisis to do it got
weaponized used one way used another way
did not galv I so crisis the bar is
going up for what it takes us for I
don't even want to think about what kind
of Crisis we would have what's the other
one guys like you who are Transcendent
figures with a message that can
overpower the status quo very rare bird
and usually they wind up um
metaphorically
symbolizing a cause that is the tantm
out to crisis like what Obama Obama was
the manifestation of America can be
better than its histo its history of
inequality he is the proof of this he
meant that to people people cried about
why his significance was so profound in
America given how we had gotten to where
we were if you decided to see it a
certain way Transcendent now did he live
up to it of course not very hard to very
hard to um so there are two things that
pull you out of this grievance cycle
because if you don't have one of those
two things I'm going to beat you I'm
going to beat you with grievance you can
sell your dream you can do your data I'm
going to dig into you a little bit I'm
going to find something and I'm going to
harp on that one thing and how all your
buddies are a problem and what you want
is dangerous scary uh and you personally
are probably scary and I'm going to win
why look at the results you want to look
at the data you do an ad bu you sit down
with a consultant the ratio of pbd sucks
to you know Chris V is good is like 6 to
one why because the negative sells why
psychologically it's easy we work to
self- protection uh and you have a
built-in cynicism uh that these people
are lying and you have to be protected
from their deception right so you have
that going for you uh then negativity is
a very powerful proxy for insight when
you're reading articles if I do a story
on pbd and it's I love this I love this
I love this I love this this guy's great
I see him with his family the guys
around him they love him it's great I
love the brand I love it I love
everything about him what a puff
piece holy cow boy did Cuomo fall for
Patrick B David I do a piece where half
this stuff is demonstrably false
negative oh you know he didn't pay for
any of this stuff and and all this and
there's really another guy and none of
it's true and you could just put out be
like there's no other guy this guy
doesn't exist people see it that's
hard-hitting journalism right there boy
woo that was that was a real pieace that
was strong why negativity yeah I come
from a place of um the right guy is is
can you move your phone away from the
mic and just put mine away as well maybe
it's mine one phone's being picked up
just put mine away as well so I I think
I don't think you're wrong because you
know mainstream media every day they
on Trump every single day they turn
him into a monster and then now you got
BLM leaders saying they're endorsing
Trump wow what you got now weird people
coming out saying listen I don't like
the fact of what they're doing to him I
relate to him and all this stuff now
they're backing him up so how about
Michael Rapaport yeah exactly that's a
weird one and the way he did it the way
he did it and while still talking
about and and musk and all these other
guys and then there was one more oh
there was one huh cardi b
b speak English but the point I'm trying
to make is I think I think the part
about being that person and you're right
about trashing them they say they say
bad news uh people tell to 11 people
good news they tell to three people and
that number makes sense like you get a
bad review for a company they're going
to tell 11 you get good review theya
they tell three I understand that part
doesn't necessarily mean it's what's
best for the country So eventually if a
person's able to evangelize a message
and sell it and is a True Believer like
it's not a phony actor that knows how to
put the words together they're going to
create momentum and they're going to
create a lot of enemies I want I want to
transition to a different story let's go
to a different story so uh uh Americans
under 30 don't trust religion or
anything else okay different story and
let's see what this goes into time I
want to come to you first with this one
here Young Americans particularly genz
and the youngest Millennials are
increasingly dis affiliating from
organized religion with up to 40%
categorizing themselves as nuns a term
encompassing atheist agnostic and those
with no specific religious affiliation
many of the young adults prefer to
Identity as nothing in particular
reflecting their reluctance to align
with the defined religious worldview
this formative distrust is attributed to
the experiences of grown up during
periods of political turmoil uh where
institutions and processes were
increasingly criticized and question
factors contributing to the
dissatisfaction of organized religion
among young adults include evolving
views on issues like abortion lgbtq
acceptance and the role of women in
churches Tom well I can tell you where
this was going from and you go to that
that statement there for formative
distrust is attributed experiences a
growing up during periods of political
turmoil and and I'm I'm going to call BS
on that it's not about the political
turmoil political turmoil is something
that's in the background and that's what
the schools are playing off this is
directly related to basically the
counterarguments that they that they get
hit and the indoctrinations that they
they get hit with in the classroom you
take a look at these kids my wife's a
teacher you see what happens n9th and
10th grade starting to have your own
opinion you're going through puberty you
want to be confident you're starting to
discover the opposite sex and things
like this there's a lot of things that
are happened psychologically at that
point and you have just spent all this
time being being told a whole ration of
things that we all know the list of they
fall under the umbrella of
indoctrination which is subtle respin of
history or complete you know skipping
and not even teaching things of history
and these folks these young kids all of
a sudden rise up and they don't know
what they believe that's the issue they
don't know what they believe they see
difference between their one parent they
see the difference between their
indoctrination and then you ask them
what do you trust what do you trust at
age 30 after they've gone to the
military or they've gone to college or
they gone to trade school and now
they've grown up in this and then they
walk out into the society that is
actually split binary with all the stuff
coming at them what do we expect we
haven't taught them to trust a platform
we haven't taught them that real truth
exists haven't taught them about you
know the the Dignity of a strong you
know self and a strong sense of right
and wrong instead we got this culture of
doubt and moral relativism that what's
good for you is good for you and this is
good for me well then where's the real
truth and where's what I really believe
and then you ask them these questions
about religion when they're 30 years old
and that's the headline you want to spin
on it but really you've built these
people that have no foundations that
haven't been taught any course structure
and this isn't all of them this is a
percent of them 40% of them the rest of
them are out there with parents like you
me others I assume you Chris we're
trying desperately to put a platform
under our kids to understand that
personal you know integrity means
something and personal integrity means
that you have to make a choice and you
have to say this is what's right and
this is what I'm going to cling to no
matter how many arrows are thrown at me
personally or I'm sitting here
scratching my head listening to my
teacher or my college professor or
others in my life tell me that that that
that that red is blue and blue is red
these kids these kids have been confused
and is it a surprise that 40% of them
feel this way when they get to be 30
years old it's not a surprise I think
it's a good point I'm really worried
about gen Z because uh we see what's
going on this narrative that's going on
they're the most educated uh generation
ever the most diverse Ed uh generation
ever yet they're the most Lost
Generation ever okay and social media
has a major part to blame in that but uh
the you always see that gener that gen Z
is so fixated on mental health and
anxiety and depression yet they have
more anxiety and depression than any
other generation there used to be
something called a midlife crisis used
to come in at age 50 or age 60 when you
know the guy used to get a Corvette and
it now your midlife crisis has now
basically been turned on its head
they're now having what's called quarter
life crisis where you have 20y olds or
25y olds or 30-year olds even basically
re-evaluating everything and it's okay
to question everything in society that's
okay but why are you questioning because
are you trying to arrive at an answer or
you just trying to be basically sort of
a pest to everything and there's sort of
these pestilent teenagers and P
pestilent genz who are just basically
looking to upend the institutions that
have basically got us to this point and
that's fine but because political
institutions are okay to be questioned
we just talked about the Divergence of
what's going on in America and the
political parties and it's okay to uh
question organized religion that's fine
but to question God like we see Megan
rapino who's sort of a face of the LGBT
movement when she misses a goal
questions God right she tears her
Achilles and she goes I guess it was
God's
fault but there's sort of this mistrust
that's going on in society and some of
it has to do with social media some some
of it has to do with deep fakes some of
it has to do with AI but at some point
there needs to be some sort of universal
truth what I always find so humorous are
these like my truthers well I'm just
living my truth hey just my truth no
listen listen there's
something called the truth and there's
just so much going on in the world where
everyone's just kind of living their own
reality and their own truth but it's
like no let's have some sort of
agreement of what is actually right or
wrong
and the collectivism and the socialism
and the Marxism that our friend Malay
was talking about is sort of taken over
it's so it it's like if you want a good
idea of that it's somehow the smartest
people the people in the Ivy League
schools the the Harvard of the world and
the yales of the world and the colombias
of the world are actually have some of
the most backward thinking this
intersection intersectionality or the
Gaze for Gaza where you're protesting
for Gaza yet if you did that in Gaza
you'd be killed okay or the de ization
or the oppressor and the oppressed
mindset there's all this stuff happening
amongst gen Z and I think it's incumbent
upon older folks to be like listen
little buddy let me tell you a little
something back in my day we used to
laugh at that like when our grandparents
would be like back in my day I used to
walk the school backwards and no shoes
uphill it's like I think it's incumbent
on sort of 40y olds and 50y olds who
aren't even that old to be like listen
you know my little 20-year-old friend
let me explain how the world kind of
works here it's why you see Osama Bin
Laden being the good guy these days in
some of these genz Tik Tok stories where
it's like what the just happened
where it's 20 years ago he was the enemy
now he's the hero things have been so
perverted and so perverse that it it
sort of takes sort of an a rebalancing
or equilibrium to be like you this
overcorrection really needs to kind of
come back to reality that's where I'm at
with this and what about I don't know if
you saw this Chris are are you Catholic
yeah are you Catholic have you been
seeing so the pope has is going woke I
know you've been seeing this guy like
he's been generally going woke and Pat I
don't know if you know this we talked
about him yesterday Chris I mean and bro
I can care less who he invites but this
whole you know going towards the
transgender and and inviting them to the
to have dinners or lunches or whatever
they're doing there's actually Rob I
sent you the link for he just punished
the other day the pope punished a a
conservative Cardinal I forgot his name
Rob I think I sent it to you he um I'll
send it to you right now uh it's he uh
uh Cardinal Burke he he took away his
money took away where he his like his
apartment and stuff because he's has
conservative views and he's going
against what the pope is doing so
they're punishing people so you can see
how Christianity just just in general
it's starting to turn turn the other way
do you know what I mean so I can see how
people I mean I mean Chris what are your
thoughts on this this is a very deep
story and situation I mean it really
goes to everything good choice um by you
um some of it you can just peel away
easily the Pope's the boss you talk
the boss you're going to have trouble
all right that's Burke's situation um
him going woke bergolo uh Pope francis's
uh real name has always been uh
radically
inclusive uh poverty obsessed uh he made
deals with drug dealers uh in the
equivalent of the favellas in Argentina
because he just wanted to help people
he's always been very expansive yeah uh
if anything he has been pushed way to
the right by the institution of
Catholics who are against him for being
to what he sees is walk in the Walk of
Jesus that's the Catholics so now that
takes us to the overarching thing of
where are we with religion uh you ask me
am I Catholic I immediately say yes oh
do I go to church every Sunday no uh do
you do what you're supposed to do
no but you're a Catholic why I was
raised Catholic okay the big data point
with this new generation is they were
not raised that way goes to Tom's Point
well then how were they raised or not
raised now you're looking at the schools
to do what was never a school's concern
before when I went to school my teacher
wasn't telling me how to be how not to
be if they didn't like my behavior they
called home and they said said your son
did this or did that deal with it that
structure has been taken away why we got
a lot of broken families so the kids
aren't raised in a faith the way they
were a generation ago they have been
introduced to a media culture social
media amplifies okay but it can't
amplify what doesn't
exist where religion is constantly under
attack and the values under which the
religion used to operate are under
attack so why would the kids be into
something that they weren't raised in
that they've only seen the ugly
underbelly of and they exist in a
secular society meaning you can believe
whatever the hell you want to believe as
long as you don't put it anybody else in
a negative way so I am not concerned by
their lack of embrace of that the
problem becomes well then what do you
Embrace okay you don't have to be
Catholic you don't have to be Christian
Christian you don't have to be Muslim
you don't have to be you don't have to
be anything um but what are you now we
start to get into what the real concern
is what are you really about every
generation fears that the next one is
soft and broken and different in this
country right our parents lived in fear
of the boob tube that thing's going to
suck out your brain and now it's us with
the phones I think we're more right than
they were but doesn't matter um so
having concerns about the Next
Generation not unusual but to Patrick's
Point policies ways mechanisms what are
you about that's where we have the
problem what are you encouraging one of
the things I would love to see from our
government is a mandated year of service
After High School totally agree I say it
all the time and it doesn't have to be
military doesn't have to be military but
it has to be for everybody my kids the
garbage man kids the postman's kids the
General's kids the Senator's
kids why because you will be inculcating
a value system that this is what we do
we surrender the me to the we uh we
don't do that in any Collective way and
even when we kind of do it like we were
talking about the First Responders the
cops we don't really see them as what
they are and what they're supposed to
mean to us oh because they don't live up
to it but the standard should still
exist and when they don't live up to it
what are they not living up to it just
reinforces that you need to have the
standard and when the overwhelming
majority lives up to a standard why do
you have a culture that is all about the
negative and showing the aberant cases
and the minority of the reality which is
where it goes wrong why do we harp only
on that the misplaced virtue is to say
well that's how we ensure it gets better
no it isn't here's something I know as a
matter of fact okay and by the way I
suck at this you want to change Behavior
you're fat okay you're not doing well at
work your kids's doing lousy in school
your kid is just a bastard you know
whatever it is bad
behavior my generation is you're going
to get a beating for this this is going
to be bad okay um does that work yes
despite the mechanism the best way this
guy Allan casden you can look it up k a
z d i n this kid this guy spent decades
studying results of how to fix bad kids
and there are bad kids you know this
idea that there's no such thing as bad
kids just bad parents no there's bad
kids because they're bad behaviors and
you got to look at the course for the
behavior then you go to the parent and
go to a million other things here's how
you change anything
okay and even the word discipline okay
discipline does not mean punishment it
means to follow and what you follow is
going to lead you to a destination you
follow something bad you're going to
wind up bad you follow good you're going
to go good positive reinforcement of
doing it the right way yields the best
results here's how we see it manifesting
itself from the simple to the Obscure
when you screw up your diet okay the
Temptation the overwhelming temptation
is to up the next meal am I right
you know you eat that breakfast you were
supposed to not have d i wonder this guy
said I wanted to get the job he's
offering me sausage I ate the sausage
the chance that you have a cheeseburger
at your next meal goes up why because
you've abandoned the standard and when
you reinforce it by I'm actually going
to go to the gym right after this
breakfast and I'm not supposed to even
work out today but I'm going to go the
positive reinforcement put you back on
track you catch your kid doing homework
instead of being on their phone and say
look at this where do you want to go to
read tonight I'm taking you out better
chance they do homework without you
telling them the next time better than
me walking in being like you on your
phone I told you not it works almost got
SL was exponentially better why positive
reinforcement we live in a society that
is consumed by the negative we don't
reward anybody for anything unless they
don't deserve it you know to your point
of intersectionality of uh the model who
doesn't look like a model anymore why we
want to celebrate this yeah the fat girl
on the cover of Victoria Secret now
there's a difference between hey
everybody's got to belong that's a
serious issue though everybody's got to
belong but the idea of the archetype mhm
the standard has to remain as well and
what we are in a phase of doing now is
rationalizing anybody's lack of success
as a function of being a victim mhm and
and here's the problem with that sounds
good can be rationalized it's not how
life
works the mechanisms of existence do not
care about the individual actor it
doesn't matter that he had to overcome
so much I'm either going to give him the
loan or I'm not going to give him the
loan I'm either going to invest or I'm
not going to invest and his story is
either impressive to me or it isn't on
the basis of where he is in that moment
we as a society because we're not based
on a lot of firm back stops of what you
guys were talking about right wrong good
bad success failure we don't even like
tests anymore right the more you do that
the more you get into this nebulous
existence where Vinnie looks like this
I'm plus 30 but we're the same and we're
okay in our own ways no Vinnie's leaner
Vinnie looks better that's the way it is
you want to look like Vinnie eat
different live different but his
genetics listen at the end of the
day uh there are outcomes there is data
we do not respect that in our culture
anymore your story hits on all of that
these kids don't know what to believe in
why would they they're not held to any
standards they don't have to win to get
a trophy um they say to you at work I
feel like you're not giving me enough
positive re enforcement for what I've
been doing you're doing what I told you
to do um yeah but I feel like I'm not
getting the reward system that I need oh
welcome to life um where you get what I
give because that's the dynamic here
we've moved away from all those things
the question is how do you get them back
which goes to your other point policies
get it back policies get it back
practices get it back these universities
that are allowing Behavior they would
never allow targeting any other group
except Jewish people their funders
should come after them their management
should come after them or it should be
changed you want to be the Bastion of
the humanities and inculcating this wide
breath of what people should take in and
understand uh then be that you want to
be lefties who are totally liberal in
your ideology and you don't want
conservative voices around then be that
but now the places who say they're all
about tolerance or allowing grotesque
intolerance why there's no standard so
how do we get back to a standard pbd
doesn't give a money that's why because
he gives money to the university where
the man or the woman stood up and said
you can protest here but I don't want to
see any signs about from the uh River to
the Sea why because it's a coded message
um it's like creating a coded black
Effigy uh oh no it isn't because blacks
are oppressed and the Jews
uh are in power they are the oppressor
oh really okay cuz tell uh the families
of the 6 million plus that were burned
uh tell them that they are that oh yeah
but that was then it's different now oh
really because all Jews are what white
go to Israel uh see how many Jews are
not white um and well so now what do you
have the rationals break down why
because the premise is weak it's just
outrage it's just grievance without any
standard the practices and the policies
will bring back the standards now here's
the overwhelming problem and it's so
interesting that you know you guys most
of you watching right now don't
understand what's happening outside this
bank vault that we're in right now you
guys are
practicing exactly the opposite of what
is happening in larger society you are
growing a brand and an ethos that is
built on Prin principles of
positivity performance okay and that is
not what wins in the game it will for
you guys you're going to be tremendously
successful but in politics which is so
powerful in our culture okay used to be
secondary it's now
primary the way to win is the opposite
of the practices and policies that'll
get us better MH and that is the
frightening thought to me it's not
Islamic Terror it's not left-wing this
or right-wing that it's that in the main
we are a
culture that is not obsessed with
improvement with virtue with Community
with
cause and that is a dangerous road and
that's why we're so perceived as weak
right now I can't believe we haven't
been hit thank God thank God thank God
if we got hit right now you know what
happened m not what happened on 9/11 of
course not where it was like Bush don't
like Bush I don't care he's in control
and he says he's going to protect us
let's go it would be the look what
happened it would be the blame game yeah
look at Biden yeah of course Biden did
this he got go he's got to leave
tomorrow of course he's got to leave
tomorrow and well what about the guys
who did this yeah yeah yeah we'll figure
that out but uh that would be our first
fight that's the scary proposition you
know you you said a couple things in
there one of is virtue and you can see
how the waterfall goes and it's so quick
and it's so easy we were we were you
know a culture where all people are
valuable and standards determine your
outcome and your rank right it doesn't
matter if you feel that you've been body
shamed if you're not fast enough or good
enough to play baseball you didn't play
baseball you didn't make the team you
know you didn't you know you you you
couldn't you couldn't do those things or
if you didn't score on the test you
didn't do it so all people are valuable
and need to be encouraged to achieve
but there are standards there and
there's going to be a rank used to be
now that you have no cut policies where
everybody's on the team and they got
like 30 kids on a team or participation
two-thirds of them suck exactly so that
was point a now we go to point B we move
from standards to
feelings I feel this I feel that and now
it's all feelings are valuable rather
than all people and individuals are
valuable and then it's virtuous for what
we do at the Special Olympics who is in
even more virtuous to apply that to all
the people with the feelings that's the
simple waterfall and we have to turn it
around you know you know it's crazy when
we're talking about religion uh we all
have I was an atheist 25 years we all
have the friend that doesn't trust
religion I had a guy the other day that
said hey why don't you put your kids in
a private school that's a Christian oh I
will never do that yeah I can't tell you
the stories but I remember as a kid when
I went to Catholic school what you know
what happened to me and I will never I
will never put my son through this and
this guy was talking to is a very very
successful guy I would never do that
okay so some of the stuff that we have
is from our upbring in what we saw what
happened to us totally valid you can't
take that away from the individual it's
one-on-one it's them respect but go to
give you a couple different instances
you're at the house your daughter brings
over a guy to the house what do you want
to know about the guy if he tells you
you know yeah what's up what's up Chris
yeah I love your stuff I love your
dog you know up hey what's up pbd
cussing
pump the braks bro okay tell me about
yourself well Mr B David you know my
father's this my dad is this okay so
tell me about oping so Mom Dad family
family of four you know uh I have an
older sister and you know what's your
older sister doing XYZ how about your
parents yeah you know um Christian what
do you no we're Catholic did you
practice Yeah we practice and here's
what we do and rituals and okay what
role did that play why I grew up in a
private you know Catholic Squad wi okay
and then tell me what your day-to-day
looks like schedule and what things are
you like the organized well I have this
and I do this and I don't okay great
routine all this stuff we can debate the
validity of any faith guess what you're
not going to know if you're right or
wrong the only time we're going to know
we're right or wrong is when we die okay
so we we got to kind of wait till that
happens hopefully it takes a long time
to know if you're right or wrong because
that just means you're living a longer
life but we can have that friendly
battle and debate it cool what I will
say is when you meet somebody that you
recruit to a company or a sports team or
when NFL teams or MLB teams are
recruiting a talent what do they want to
know they want to know upringing like a
5-2 player what do you want to know I
want to meet his mom and dad what was a
discipline like what did you guys do oh
that's a strong Christian family that's
a strong you know such and such okay
great so Faith played a role yes then
what do you get with faith you get
structure you get fear which you need
fear cuz you need a little bit of that
to not do the dumbest things that you
know you're going to do in life you're
going to be taught certain values and
principles on what you're doing uh
there's a certain level of expectations
on the type of a character you're going
to have if you have that so but one
could say but who cares about that you
know religion is the reason why we have
all these wars no religion is not the
reason for the wars it's how people used
religion it's the same thing that gun is
not the reason why all this stuff
happens is because people use gun cars
are a lot easier to kill a lot of people
you can drive a car into an audience of
50 people boom kill them no problem and
you do it like this how come how come it
doesn't happen every single day that it
happens because we have to have some
kind of control over the weapon that we
have right so I think it's a very big
mistake that's being made today with
faith uh I think the quality of hires
are going to get lower because the
values and principles are going to be
lower um I think culturally longterm you
know this this recklessness where you
don't have a certain level of pride in
what you're doing I I would much rather
hire somebody that's got a certain level
of discipline upbringing in a
faith-based family than somebody that
was Reckless I don't believe in anything
I don't fear anything yeah I'm going to
be okay it it it hurts the possibility
of having a stable person there so
they're going to continue doing this and
selling it it is what it is but my
concern goes in a complete different way
than from this and by the way we're
having this conversation with somebody
ask him a question I said so you got
five communities to live in this guy's
like but you don't understand what
they're doing with Hamas
and da d d da I said really yeah cool so
you think it's what but you got to know
the Jews are this I said oh okay no
problem I said let me simplify the
question for you by the way some people
going to hate this question but your
answer is the answer and what's the
question here's the question you have a
choice you have five communities you can
raise your family in I'm asking this guy
the question by the way some of you are
going to be very offended by this
question oh well you answer the question
I didn't answer the question you answer
the question I so you got five
communities one Community is filled with
white
Mormons okay cool another Community is
filled with black Christians okay
another Community to raise your kids is
filled with Jews it's 85% Jewish another
Community is 85% Muslim which Community
you want to raise your family this guy's
black without hesitation guess what he
said guess
Jewish he said the the Mormons yeah
black Christians then went Jewish then
went Muslim I said wait what did you
just
say and he's like well you know I said
why not why why are you feeling this
way well you know I'm like I didn't tell
you any answer you just answered the
question by the way for me for 10 years
I lived around 95% Muslims yep I live
there and I met a lot of great but why
is it that Muslims feel safer Coming to
America why are they leaving why do they
come here why do they feel safer coming
to places like this how come Americans
don't go to move to Palestine how come
Americans are not moving to some of
these countries these are valid
questions to be asking are these
questions that could offend the
community of course are people going to
make reaction videos to this here you go
again Pat shows his true colors go and
make it totally fine with it I'm
comfortable in my skin but to me is we
have to ask if a community is teaching
certain values and principles that you
feel safer with guess what we ought to
go back to teaching some level of faith
praying to God that we don't believe in
because it encourage a level of faith if
you want to win a life you need faith if
you want to build a business you need
faith if you want to have your marriage
work out you need Faith you need faith
for anything big you want to do in your
life okay and Charlie moner one of the
univers I was watching this morning
early this morning this lady is asking
him the question and says hey so you
know what do you think about the
obituary and all this other stuff and
your life and how you've lived and you
know what you do with this and your kids
and he's breaking down all these uh
different stories he says you know me
and uh uh Buffett we've both lived in
the same house for decades same house
for decades you know where we are right
now and at the end of the day you know
the way I live my life is going to tell
my kids how to live their lives and you
know what kind of people they're going
to be and our family was a lot about
values and principles and all this other
stuff I think we need more of that today
I think we need a lot of faith today
anyone with a big Vision or dream needs
to have faith it's hard to do it without
it anyways that's my thoughts we can get
to the next story here on uh uh what we
got okay which one do we want to go to
let's pick and choose do we want to talk
China do we want to talk dairo do we
want to talk Trump Trudeau or Maverick's
Mark Cuban pick the story about musk
what do you think which story you want
to go to I'm open which story you want
which musk musk went to Israel kind of
you want to do that story okay what page
is that on
what page is a musk story on I think the
bottom eight I don't know I don't have
these little prep packs that you guys
have prep pack Rob what page oh there
you go okay here we go page eight Elon
Musk except
for Mr Cuomo he doesn't have the notes
uh okay Elon Musk on visit to Israel
says those intent on murder must be
neutralized Wall Street Journal story
after visiting an Israeli Community
attack by Hamas stated those intent on
murder must be neutralized he expressed
concerns about the proper Anda promoting
violence saying the propaganda must stop
that is training people to be murderers
in the future during his visit to Israel
musk remarked it was jarring to see the
scene of the massacre while discussing
the attacks on Israel civilians he
emphasized the need to make Gaza more
prosperous for lasting peace saying I
would love to help Israel's
communication Minister schokari
announced an agreement and principle had
been reached with musk regarding the use
of starlink uh uh satellite units
highlighting the importance of
controlling technology in the conflict
with Hamas Adam well it's interesting
because uh musk after basically taking a
lot of heat over some certain
anti-semitic rhetoric which I think was
overblown anyway uh went to go see the
atrocities after what happened in
October 7th and he actually met with um
BB Netanyahu and Isaac Herzog the
president of Israel and uh he basically
gave a three-pronged approach I this is
not any situation that could be
oversimplified but here was Elon Musk
approach what could be done with Gaza um
and I actually fully agree with it it's
number one you need to destroy Hamas so
anyone that doesn't uh understand that
this is Isis this is al- Qaeda this is
el- nusra this is bah Haram they are we
talked about having uh a belief in a
higher power but there's
extremists that basically believe that
they are Divine from God jihadists that
basically it's their way or the highway
and there's no negotiating with these
people they believe in this there's no
way of getting away from that now
there's a whole separate conversation of
how you get these people and how you get
them out of the tunnels and they're
hiding literally in hospitals and using
civilians as human Shields that's a
whole another conversation but you need
to eradicate these people by the way
when we went to Afghanistan and irq we
killed a half a million civilians zero
apologies okay horrible which is
because they they deserve to be
in jail Bush junr and Rumsfeld oh he's
dead that's that's crazy war
criminals totally a conversation that
could be on the table but nothing will
be held accountable of that the point is
that number one Hamas will need to be
destroyed but number two how do you
rebuild Gaza after this okay um what has
clearly happened over since 2006 after
Israel has basically disengaged from
Gaza and
Hamas basically was elected and they
haven't had an election since it's not a
democracy it's authoritarian regime
basically where a terrorist organization
runs the country and they basically took
out fata or the pla the Palestinian
Liberation Organization Authority and
they uh the the gentleman who is
apparently runs the pla um give me his
name again um who runs the top guy he's
88 years old runs the pla yeah he's the
is the main guy anyway he hasn't even
been to Gaza since 2006 because he fears
for his life what's his
name who runs
F you know his name you've seen his face
he's 88 years old okay okay the point is
this they need to rebound so billions of
dollars so you can find it Rob uh
billions of dollars have been funneled
into Gaza from all around the world and
what have they done with it they haven't
built schools they haven't built
hospitals they haven't built uh Parks
they haven't built basically
civilizations that that that teach kids
the right things to do they've built
tunnels they built their War chest
they've built basically a military
apparatus to basically destroy Israel
from The River To The Sea they must be
free so they need to re-educate these
people learn how to not hate and learn
how to just live their life but the most
important thing by far is that they need
economic Prosperity so you know there's
no reason that Gaza which is essentially
50 mil South of Tel Aviv which is an
amazing city a worldclass city there's
no reason that Gaza the beaches the
beautiful area on the Mediterranean Sea
if they actually did this the right way
and they focused on GDP not war that
they can't be the Dubai or the Abu Dhabi
of the Mediterranean we've seen the case
examples of what's going on in the Gulf
States whether it's Qatar whether it's
in the um a UAE like there there's a
precedent for this and we're seeing the
precedent even more overblown with
what's going on with NBS and Muhammad B
Salman basically trying to modernize
modernize the Middle East and basically
saying we can't live in the Dark Ages
anymore but the countries that still
live in the Dark Ages the Syria of the
world the Yemen of the world the irans
of the world that are ruled by molas you
see what their GDP is it's next to
nothing and the West Bank in Gaza has
the same GDP as Jordan as Egypt as Syria
as Lebanon the the race to the bottom in
these countries is a is a race to
nowhere but if you actually want to
educate your citizenry and educate the
youth and and have a life that every
person in this world wants a safe family
a a economic ability the the mobility to
go where you want to go to live the life
you want to be to to have a job to earn
that's something that I think is is is
requirement for Gaza so you you
interviewed the son of hamasa founder
right
you green Prince yeah the green Prince
what was that like talking to him what
perspective did he give you never met
any great interview never met anybody
like him before um it's was so
interesting to me to see people discount
his
perspective as someone who doesn't know
what he's talking about the son of the
founder yeah who was a killer for
Hamas then goes to prison sees Hamas
brutalizing its own members says wait
what is this about goes to his father
he's in prison goes to his father he
like what's going on realizes that the
mission has been
lost and goes to the Israelis and says
Hamas is actually the problem for my
people and stays in the position as his
father's
guy and giving information to Israel to
stop suicide bombings spends 10 years
never gets detected he thinks people
were suspicious but it was kind of too
far-fetched to believe it and his
father's the big guy so how could it be
he then
leaves comes here starts talking about
how bad this Hamas situation is and how
wrong it's being
construed then he decides he needs to
get his head straight and he goes lives
in Southeast Asia in some little island
for 10 years doing yoga and losing all
this weight literally yeah and then
October 7th happens and he's like I
gotta I got to make my witness the first
impressive thing is of course the story
how can you check more boxes than this
guy who would you rather talk to about
this oh well he's brainwashed by the
IDF
how why would he's not even in Israel
you know he's an American citizen by the
way and when he came here they thought
he was a Jihadi and they wanted to kick
him out and you know because his
father's the head of Hamas you know um
that's all America needs to hear so he's
had his troubles um so the reaction was
very the second thing is the reaction
that the people here who don't like what
he's saying well this guy just hates
Palestinians he is Palestinian right
yeah but he uh doesn't believe in uh
two-state solution he believes you can't
have one when you have a terror
organization running one of the two
states then you can't have it then he
makes another point that to me is a Blow
Away point and I don't understand why
we've ever allowed this to
be uh Elon
musk good for him for going to learn
about a situation that he clearly didn't
understand in context good for him that
should be the end of the analysis until
we see what he does with his reach going
forward but it won't be why because
we're addicted with the negative and I
shouldn't even have started with the
positive I should have like said oh
there after he did all these bad things
because that's what we're about that is
not what I'm about let's see what he
does he did something almost nobody in
American society will do which is be
open to the fact that maybe they got it
wrong when they were criticized for
something other than doubling down let's
see what he does next however why is it
on Israel to rebuild Gaza or to make
Gaza or the West Bank into anything why
isn't the only condition for any chance
of a two-state solution is to relieve
Israel of the burden of artificially
supporting these other areas if you want
to be a state make Israel pull out you
can have any kind of intercourse you
want you know work whatever you figure
out what rules work for both sides
there's a big spectrum of that
everywhere in the world right some
people like people from places some
people don't like them as much they
Preference they
disadvantage and then let the Arab
Brotherhood and the
Palestinians make their own way forward
Ward why is it on Israel if you don't
want well they're in control because
it's the only way for them to stay safe
let them do what we do we don't make
Mexico right you want the Border put in
place we get to control who comes across
if you with us then we fight that's
the rule just like with Canada just like
between France and Germany anywhere else
that idea that Israel's got to make aaza
that is populated with people who are
under the influence of a group think
that Jews should not exist that's never
going to work and it never has some
people are new to this situation I've
been covering it for 25 years and it's
been going on long before I was born my
father was obsessed with it and how
nonsensical it was musk did the right
thing let's see what he does next the
idea of how do you get to a better place
in the Middle East first of all if it
were simple we wouldn't be dealing with
this kind of turmoil it's the only
situation like it I wish that we were
paying more attention to two other
situations other than what's happening
in Israel look it matters they're
killing a lot of young people they're
killing a lot of women it's horrible and
everybody should want it to stop but we
also know the nature of War and what we
did after 9/11 and we didn't have any of
the existential threat that Israel does
right um we kept going until we didn't
want to anymore oh yeah but that was
wrong okay maybe maybe not but don't
think that there's a new set of rules
for them now but if you really care
about this just to the American mindset
obviously it matters and it has to be it
has to be reconciled but to our
obsession with it why don't you feel
like that about what the Saudis are
doing in Yemen there's hundreds of
thousands of people being slaughtered
there why because they're not Saudi
Arabia's kind of Muslim that's why why
doesn't that bother you there are a
million Muslim
Wagers in a camp being reprogrammed by
the Chinese yep m a million we don't
know anything about the conditions and
whenever we do find anything out it's
horrible crickets why the selectivity of
the outrage betrays the agenda and and
there is an agenda at play you may not
know that you're being worked by an
agenda you may think you're acting in
good faith but it's happening and the
way you know that it's happening is that
your position doesn't make sense no I'm
Pro Palestine they shouldn't be like
this but you don't know Palestine you
don't know the history you don't know
the dynamic you're completely
discounting one side of the equation out
of convenience and Advantage so we just
have to look but you don't care about
any of these other places you can't tell
me that Israel is more of a threat to
Palestine or Gaza or the West Bank than
China is to a group of a million people
that it has in a zoo M but you don't
care the same way why that's the
question for people to ask the problem
we have in our society is they don't do
what musk did they don't ask themselves
why they don't hear the criticism and
say what they do is they keep swiping
until they find somebody saying the guy
who just asked me to ask myself why is
actually a piece of as a Turk s
he's actually you know this shill or
that shill or he's and you get away from
it you get back to your safe space of
your confirmation bias but in the Middle
East look it's going to be like this
until we're gone why because the Arab
Brotherhood is not a Brotherhood they
don't treat the Palestinians like
anything special they never have in fact
they say really ugly things about
Palestinians and even their virtue as
Arabs okay and everybody in the region
and everybody who's culturally educated
knows this so there's a lot of
going on but why isn't it on them to
build up their brothers why is it on
their existential enemy to build up
their brothers the situations never made
sense what a great word selectivity of
outrage right I mean you pick and choose
what you lose your mind over and that's
exactly what's happening what thoughts
you yeah CU because it's one thing like
and AER with the Armenians it's like
it's like whatever is hot Chris people
go to it but then I was going to go to
Adam's Place when we said cuz right now
Chris gaza's flat they they bombed the
hell out of it I have two questions one
for you Adam is you know now that
they're gone and uh internal documents
leaked uh from Israel which they were
kind of like well it wasn't supposed to
hit the public where they're saying
where all these Palestinians are you
know they want the West to take them
they want Canada to take them they want
everybody to take um Egypt they want to
take all these uh Palestinians do you
really think they're going to be be able
to come back to Gaza all the misplaced
people that are gone now do do you
really do you genuinely think that I
dude I have no clue if they're going to
come back or not they need to rebuild
that country and that City in order what
are they coming back to there nothing
but Chris brought up a great question
The Selective
outrage if Egypt cared they would take
in these people if Jordan cared they
would take they say we have too many
yeah
exactly help out your fellow brethren
believe me Israel will take in any Jews
that that need want to come to Israel
you can literally go get make aiyah if
you're Jewish and literally they will
take you in so why won't they do that
the same for their fellow M Muslim or
it's a genocide how come there no Jews
with any significant footprint in any of
these other countries except the United
States and they have over 20% of their
population is Arab if it were a
genocidal notion why would they be
having that and let me tell you having
watched genocide in action this is not
what it looks like 100%
one more thing genocide how many syrians
were killed in the Civil War under
Bashar Assad millions of syrians were
killed where was your Outreach when your
fellow Muslims people were murdering
other Muslims what about Boo Haram in
Northern Africa when they took all those
kids and we cared for like a week and a
half and then they're like oh they're
not still back and when I asked Obama
about the red line in Syria you know I
was like what kind of line is just keeps
moving you know what I mean it kind of
defeats the metaphor right he was like
oh Slow Down slow down well Chris we
have a light red line and we have a dark
red line he's gassing his own people and
I got to tell you you know who was
pissed at me everybody everybody was
like what do you want us to do what do
you want us to go in there and get
involved in this isn't our problem this
is him on his it's totally okay to kill
your own people yeah so but you know if
you want to self-defense and kill the
bad guys we have a major problem Point
goes back an hour we cared about the
revolution in Iran about what month 5
minutes because because and and let's be
honest you know if people want to be
honest why because they had a wave of
advocates in this country that were
attractive Wells spoken people yeah and
that works on TV and the media and I
don't I don't in any way question the
authenticity of their cause I talk with
these women and some men um it's
authentic it's real they're now involved
in what's going on in Israel in the
Middle East and they're being treated
horribly uh for bad reason but we cared
and then yeah it's gone can I one that a
uniquely American thing by the way this
was the most ironic thing and I showed
it to you is the same people that were
protesting the regime in Iran the same
people and I interviewed one the the one
lady with the hair she's amazing at the
freedom Forum um they're ironically the
Iranians are the loudest protesters
against Hamas and in favor of the Jewish
because they understand they know what
it happens to have religious exactly
that's right and if you got rid of Iran
you know if you want to beat Biden over
the head with something MH I do not
share a lot of the objections to the
deal that was in place I am a
something's better than nothing person
the IR nuclear deal me yeah you had
something going on there that allowed
some kind of foothold under Obama you
yeah uh that was that was better than
better than nothing okay it was a bad
deal was a bad deal again it's easy to
call something a bad deal if you can't
make another okay so
Iran has to be dealt with and they don't
want to deal with it
why there's no clear advantage in it
there's a lot of risk right you got
zealots you know you got zealots there
who are way too happy with a one forone
exchange you got a war weary public but
Iran is kicking our ass all over the
place they caused the troubles in Syria
they were fueling all this stuff in Iran
in Iraq and Afghanistan inen we see it
in Yemen we see it Africa they're
beating they're beating people to death
for not wearing their their hijab right
and they you know they they're getting
and the Optics of it is like they're
eating our lunch you know and I remember
it starting with
akad Coming to America and there were
all these people who didn't want him to
have a forum and I was like no give them
a forum right here what this is gu about
look at the smile on his face when he
talks about his disrespect for Western
values and how we're such Hypocrites see
this guy know what you oppose mhm and if
you were to come after them and treat
them like what they are which is the
root cause of a lot of your problems in
that region because they're perverting
the faith of over a billion and a half
people MH but we don't do it see that's
a policy that I would love to see a
Nikki Haley or any I don't care who it
is to be honest with you um because I'm
not obsessed with the personal I really
believe if somebody really wants to Gig
and they check basic boxes now we get to
the determination the consistency and
what their plan is right so I don't like
to get all caught up in the who's worse
than who because you never get to better
how big of a deal is it that K Koch
brothers are not supporting Haley big
tell me why money money is the blood um
and it gives her an advantage over all
these guys who aren't self-funded only
ramas Swami can keep himself in the race
so um it and it's also a lot of people
uh you know Trump hurt some of the coke
cache but a lot of people on the right
respect the Cokes and they're like an
offset Soros um to to a lot of people on
that side so I think uh it it's an
unqualified positive C money is
establishment money though right because
Coke you owe them favors if you take
money from them you take money from
anyone you owe them favors there is an
attraction to the self-funded personal
though then what are you saying what if
the idea is well we don't want the
establishment well what's more
establishment than an independently
wealthy person unless they made their
money in some untraditional way but the
money is not what scares me and the idea
that you're going to owe people back you
doesn't scare me either it's about how
you do it uh and you know what your
guidelines are but if you were to own
something like this like here would be
my two-point policy plan okay this is
what I would say if I were advising
someone to
run I don't care who I work with I'm
going to do several things at the border
one whatever the physical thing is that
they say they need I'm gonna finish it I
also know that we're not a wall away
from being safe mhm I am going to Triple
all of our processing capacities I am
going to Triple our security capacity so
you don't have the men and women who are
keeping us safe there burdened by case
dispositions I'm going to build out
these massive places to humanely house
probably better than where they're
coming from uh take care of their kids
to keep all the families together all
night they're human beings
and I'm going to process them
immediately and I'm going to change the
laws of what Asylum means and we're
going to have a debate and you guys are
going to tell me either economic Asylum
is okay or it isn't and if it is under
what guidelines but once we get our
rules set right and the guys who run it
CBP have been saying for a generation
the rules don't work on Asylum because
we don't allow economic Asylum except in
the special deal we cut Venezuela
and once we have our rules and I have my
processing and I have my places you come
in illegally I catch you I put you in
the center because you if you if you
claim Asylum I have new rules so I can
FastTrack you you don't check the box
you'll figure out what the boxes are now
you're going to check the box I'm going
to process you and I'm going to send you
back it's going to be expensive but it's
going to be less expensive than what
we're doing right now and I'm going to
take the people who are here they're all
paying taxes we'll figure out there iip
status later sounds like you're going to
be voting for Trump everybody's pay if
if he had gotten more of it done because
to him the wall was a metaphor that's
all he needed you know they made that up
on the campaign bus we were never a wall
away from safety the numbers were down
why because melan Google that name MC a
l n n when he ran Homeland Security CBP
before it this he wound up leaving
because he couldn't take what was
happening with Trump but this guy's uh
back to our earlier conversation about
the institutions in the Deep State this
is a guy who' been there forever was
doing the job for the right reasons he
cut these deals with the home countries
and with Mexico that was the key we
cannot have everybody be processed at
our border you should set up
infrastructure and pay in the home
countries to have processing done then
unless it's extreme so if you do that as
your domestic issue that's my only
domestics question for you can I'm
getting Iran can Trump do anything to
get your vote could Trump do something
to get my vot anything to get your Vote
or is it that personal and frustrating
to not give him the vote well first of
all uh and this should be enough he has
made life hard for my family
gratuitously okay I used to speak to the
president on a regular basis and I would
speak to his guys on an all the time
basis okay and I did not go after him
personally I interviewed him
routinely I was one of the people to let
him do the phoner interviews and we were
smart enough at CNN to say offer to
Hillary offer to Hillary and her
campaign would be like no we're not
giving you you know an interview like
every third day that's on them he wanted
the opportunity we gave it to him oh but
the phone he should be in front of a
camera whatever you know you either
making your your your case or you're not
but you make it hard for me I'm no
different than you if he had done
something that made it harder for your
kids in school
is he going to get your vote if we have
trumped it yeah to me I I uh I'm purely
based on policy because I don't need to
have a relationship with that individual
okay meaning uh uh will there be
personal stuff that if somebody goes
after my brother and and that side
absolutely but that that's not Trump's
doing that's the establishment doing
bled wasn't Trump I'm not I'm not
blaming him for that what happened to
even you bro what happened to you is I'm
not blaming him for me either although I
know he saying is he he went after my
family though you know he you know and
and and what he did well he did by
weaponizing the left went after your
family the establishment went after your
family there is no question that we have
had or travails yeah um you will never I
mean we talk on a regular basis you will
never hear any sense of pity party
coming from me I'm no victim my
brother's no victim oh I totally get
that that's not that's not why
a there were things happened that
obviously I'm not happy about that I
don't think was fair um and that's okay
because life is life life is not fair
fair is the only four-letter word my
therapist always says uh and I love that
line so I'll steal it but um I don't go
policy only I think policy is a Panacea
in a lot of ways you know it's a really
a cure all if you can get to it but the
people
matter uh and if you don't act with
integrity and you want to Lead Me by the
way it's not I'm not saying it's the
standard for me I'm flawed I don't want
to lead I'm not asking for your vote I
don't think I'm the best of us I think
I'm the rest of us if you want to be
elevated well then there's going to be a
standard accountability he does not meet
that standard now the best argument for
him is oh but Biden does I didn't say
that oh yeah but you've said Biden's a
nice guy he is a nice guy I loved his
son bo bo would have been an amazing
leader for our country he would have
been a generational leader he was n uh
Joe was nice when my father died he said
nice things to us that's nice do I think
he's the best of us no do I think he's
the best we can do as president
absolutely not do I think he's the best
the Democrats can do hell no if you got
those two though you going to sit it out
or you gonna go oh if it's if it's Biden
Trump look for me again um we survived a
trump
Administration uh would we survive
another one yes yes I don't think
there's any greater risk To America with
him than with Biden and for people who
are now going to attack me and say what
are you talking about Trump is like this
crazy man well look you know as Patrick
says the data is the data nobody was
trying to kill us when Trump was
president in a way that they're not now
if anything there's more hostility and
you can have reasons for that any way
you want I'm just saying
existentially I'm not afraid of a trump
presidency um EX existentially I'm not
afraid of another Biden presidency
because unlike many people in America I
believe that the country is much
stronger than any individual leader um
we survived the Russia thing we survived
January 6th we survived having Biden as
a gaff machine we survived uh Congress
uh going after each other and doing
nothing for the rest of us we survive
these things are we better for it no uh
should we be doing things differently
yes I think it happens I don't know when
I don't even know why but you know in
terms of who I'm going to vote for I
would really have to see where we are at
that moment in
time uh and so you're open to Trump vote
I am always open and I'll tell you this
people say oh you've never
voted for a republican in your life
wrong and not only have I the first vote
I ever cast was for a republican who was
that
1988 I'm a freshman in
college um duckus is running against
George HW
Bush um
Dukakis honorable man good man one of
the early victims of media savagery by
the way with what they did with his wife
but um to to me he was too close to my
father's story and it bothered me that
if it's going to be him then it should
have been Pop I voted for Bush was he
the guy that they put in the uh the tank
and he just looked like the helmet that
was like this yeah it just was not a
good for so so okay but so I'm open look
John McCain okay may rest in peace when
he was running against Obama I believed
in him as a leader and look people will
talk about him personally and all these
things he lived through tremendous
things of course there were going to be
scars on him of course he had personal
limitations and some
eccentricities but he defined his own
fate if it had stayed without the
economy going down he was a strong
choice for keeping America safe when the
economy happened he'd already sold
himself out but I was very strongly
supportive Chris for you to even think
about the two votes you have four years
of results with Trump four years of
results three years of results with
Biden data shows it's not even close and
I think that's the part you know with
with so I talked to a lot of guys in
different places and we have a
relationship and I have a wide range of
audience I like sports so Sports
Liberals are like dude I watch your
but I don't agree with your Paul like
dude I just talking about sports I'm
just kind of talk I like Hollywood and
I'm freaking like I know hip-hop like
from you know 1990 till 2003 end there
it ends there but I know hipop and and I
know some real go back a little bit more
Big Daddy Kane in there I didn't come to
the St till 1990 Big Daddy Kane is
strong come get some you bum you'd love
him yeah so for me my range is I'm so
interested in so many different topics
but to me I think sometimes the creative
the the the liberal side is like oh if
there is anybody you can NE if they find
out where you live in your community you
voted for him dude your tires will be
slashed every flipping day for a month
straight and they you know what kind of
things they would do to you if and that
fear of losing that uh uh Community I
have no fear of losing that Community
they're they're not for me Chris if you
voted for Trump you know what they would
do to you they would torture you they
would torture you listen I didn't say I
would vote for Trump I'm saying you have
to be open to the circumstances at the
time and to me the alternative is Joe
Donald Trump to me yeah has betrayed the
trust and the standard of a leader for
America and he has done it many times
over and that's part of the result
structure for me I can't just look at
the economy and migration at the
southern border this is a guy who has
reinforced too many things that I think
are destructive to human life so what's
more so I would have to see where are we
in the state of play at that time and
what is he offering has he changed it
all but I got to be open but I'm telling
you it's if he's depending on me to win
he's not in good shape if if it was like
if you're thinking about the risk of
crossing the border and that guy you
know build a wall and oh we're not going
to let him build a wall and now Biden
wants to build a wall because like
almost every policy had they stopped
they're bringing it back like it's
validating but the wall was always a
distraction what made the difference
under Trump was two things one people
believed they were going to have bad
outcomes if they came to America with
Trump and that was impactful and keeping
them away now you can make the argument
that that's not the message America
should be sending out but it was true
two was was the deals that they cut with
the home countries and with Mexico that
Biden got rid of as soon as he came in
to do that stupid thing that one
Administration does when it beats
another to erase the Legacy as much as
they can it was a huge mistake and what
Trump didn't do even though he had the
political clout and numbers to do it was
do all these other things that CBP has
been begging for to change the rules to
change the processing capabilities the
housing capabilities instead it devolved
into this sanctuary cities and
the wall and the brown Menace and the
bad ombres and that's all cheap
demagoguery that didn't fix it he could
have fixed it and didn't world the world
is a show today because nobody
fears our president and if we had
another Biden all the people that you
want to do good for they would get
destroyed under another Biden because
nobody fears no respects Biden he could
be a sweetheart of a guy I don't know
that but how do you think Trump would
get things done when you know there's
going to be an election right away that
is a a Calver right that balances it out
so now he doesn't have Congress how's he
going to get anything done nobody's
going to work with him well that's his
job though and and but he didn't do it
the last time he was in there he
couldn't get deals but there's a reason
for it because sometimes on your first
term you don't want to be too aggressive
because you were concerned about your
second you think Trump was suffering
from a lack of aggression I would I
would say sometimes you he's a legacy
guy you know he's a legacy guy so for a
guy that's a legacy guy he doesn't want
to be a one-term guy and and don't
forget that right before he even got in
the fake Russia collusion that everybody
was pushing Chris CNN was pushing it too
every like he came in with Russia Russia
it was just four years of he's
compromised he's this how are you
supposed to do your job when every
single day every freaking news media
Outlet is saying that you're a Russian
asset I just have one question I have
one question on Trump and and you're
talking to somebody who was
diametrically opposed to even
considering voting for him four years
ago now I got the Trump stamp on my
lower back now but um yeah I'm
definitely considering voting for Trump
this time not even a question the
question is though how much can he
really get done in just a one four-year
term this time because it's not like
it's a two-term president he had his
four Hiatus now he's going to get done
again I don't even know where you get a
sense of confidence that that's what he
wants Patrick says he's a legacy guy I
would say okay maybe his own personal
Legacy of aggrandisement uh the guy's
never been about anything big than
himself in his entire life I agree with
that he's never built anything that
didn't have his name on it uh and he's
never run anything well that didn't go
straight into the ground so the guy's a
little bit of a paper tiger for me in
that regard now you're saying yeah but
compare him to the alternative well
that's what the voters are going to do
um you know am I looking at him as uh my
personal Best Choice or the countries no
do I think there better people in that
party yeah the problem that I think is
happening and it's valid is there's this
sort of like Roman ification of trump
because look at the alternative it's
like if if you're running against Biden
it's like well the good old days yeah I
know I'm with you but it's about what
your standard is you know Patrick and
and you and me and Vinnie and Tom we're
sitting here talking about we got to get
back to values we got to get back to
standards we got to back to Trump's not
your guy Trump's not your guy Trump
trump is the here's the rule I'm going
to break it I'm going to get away with
it because I know the game and everybody
does this so it's okay you know what's
the great thing about data again first
three years preco pre the left did
everything they could to get the you
know instead of making China the enemy
they made him the enemy first three
years it was on fire no war peace things
were good of course media destroyed
America dividing them against each other
hardcore left against right left against
right you know Trump's the boogeyman
then Co happened and they said nope
Trump's the enemy Trump's the enemy
Trump's the enemy and the people that
took the vaccine they got the vaccine
quickly because because of trump but if
he got it quick Kamal said I would never
take the vaccine that quickly then went
the party change oh we should take the
vaccine now then it's like what do you
stand for you just stand for what the
establishment told you well look Trump
did the same thing right you are right
operation warp speed I live next to a
guy who was a fundamental part of it it
would not have happened had former
president Trump not cleared so many of
the obstacles and made the funding
necessary and did exactly what our
leaders should in situations I don't
know how this is normally done but it's
not going to be done that this way now
and I don't care what rules I'm breaking
let's just get this done it was
extraordinary then it became weaponized
politically and he had to get quiet
about it it's the only time I've ever
heard him boot is when he would say I
think you should take the vaccine and
people would boo him why it was
weaponized by his own people um which
doesn't make a lot of sense but it does
show you know what it always showed to
me it's not about Trump okay the
grievance the Animus that he is a symbol
of that he motivates and that he says I
will fight for you I'm your guy that
allows people to say look I don't want
to be this guy except for the money but
um he is for me and he's against what I
fear most was the only time you saw that
that's truly the dynamic it's not Trump
trump Didn't Start the Fire Trump didn't
create this Trump recognized it that's
right Trump recognized it and he used it
and the only time you saw it was on the
vaccine where when those people no I
don't trust government I don't trust now
you're not now you're not my guy anymore
you became an instrument of what I'm
worried about I boo you it's the only
time it's ever happened because it's the
only time he went against his read on
what those people were going to want uh
so again I'm with you on the data but
I'll tell you where P you got to believe
that somebody can give you the same
policies that you want and get more of
them done than Trump I'll and this is
personal with you and Trump clearly
obviously totally get it if if anyone
did anything to disrespect my family I'd
have a hard time voting for them but
where Pat is absolutely right you talked
about this two podcasts ago Trump is not
the enemy I think we've all been fed
this this thing of Lies where it's he's
the enemy he's against America he's
anti-American he's in bed with Russia
and it turned out that was actually
false yeah I don't I don't I don't
believe and I never believed he was in
bed with Russia what I believed and I
still believe is that investigation was
a waste of time
AB intio oh that's not what you were
saying when you were at CNN yes it was
go take a look but you still covered it
that's the job you got a president who's
under investigation by special
prosecutor you're not going to ignore it
unless you're Fox and and even they had
to do uh some of it what I said from the
beginning and what has always been true
is his campaign did stupid things that
they shouldn't have done that guys who
are in that business know not to do when
it comes to who they talk to who wants
to help them and what kind of meetings
they take that is considered collusion
as a behavior not a crime collusion is
not a crime conspiracy is they were
nowhere near conspiracy um Donald Trump
was never in my estimation anything like
compromised by Russia did he stupidly
say Wikileaks do more of it and Russian
troll Farms do this and do that and when
you say like that are you baiting a
media that is desperate to come after
you yes and you're going to get what you
ask for with the media when it comes to
negativity and that was always true and
those behaviors were wrong should they
have been investigated criminally that
way and to that degree no um was the
dossier being paid for ultimately by uh
Hillary's uh Team should that have been
known sooner yes was all of it about the
dossier no all of it was not about the
dossier I I know we got to run I have
one last question for you hurry up I got
to pee Trump wins let's go to this
magical you know January 20th 2025 Trump
wins he's the new president you know
again remix Vibe how ugly will it get
with the media especially the CNN's
msnbc's of the world mainstream media
knowing what you know you know taking
sort of a bird's ey not as bad as you
think okay tell us why look e even look
all I control is my voice within my show
on news Nation okay I don't have any
control over news Nation I control what
comes out of my face on news Nation on
my podcast and on your podcast I would
give him a fair shot uh why because the
country needs him now if he's in the
position if the country's put him in
that position then he's got to get it
are they going to come after him yeah if
they have an opportunity will people be
a little sick of it and will that matter
yes if it doesn't rate and resonate they
won't do it as much will the Democrats
if they have the authority cuz we got to
see what happens in the election would
they go after him a new I don't think so
so you're saying third time's the charm
for Trump I don't know that it's the
charm I think that he has a very
legitimate chance of winning uh which to
me is a sad commentary about the go
because you should be able to beat Biden
based on Biden's not making a case for
himself and not defending propositions
that are being used against him which is
what an election is about right you
don't tell me your story somebody else
will and you won't like the ending they
should be able to do better than Trump
uh the Republicans based on policy and
principle should be able to do better
than Trump but people get what they want
and I think he's very well positioned
even with all the litigation because
people don't believe in the system
that's uh Prosecuting him but if he gets
elected I give him a fair shot I would
invite him on the show I'd cover his
administration and I would do a case by
case moving forward not what we live
through in the past it's not good job uh
by the way way for those of you watching
this uh I trust at one point you hated
what Chris said you love what Chris said
you probably hated what I said you love
what I said you hated what Vinnie said
you love what Vinnie said and the list
goes on for everybody else here I don't
care I like these conversations period
love them I love these conversations
these are my favorite conversations
because to me I you're not the um you
know when we talk yeah we're not going
to agree some of the best podcast you
and I have ever done is not recorded
it's on a phone call that would just
talk it's the best conversation is
because it's just you let a rip but that
maybe it's being Armenian maybe it's
being ass Syrian maybe it's being
Persian like we like a good argument a
good debate but then we want to go have
food together and sit down and talk and
do all that stuff I think there's some
similarities that with the you know the
Italian side there's a but I believe
what I believe what you're about you see
we've made it all about the conflict
where if you disagree there's there's
got to be a problem like we're Jets
versus dolphin fans you know that's
Sports leave it there MH nothing gets
better in business if you can't be open
to descent I mean you've been making so
much success so much in your young life
it's not because you've been closed off
to anybody who doesn't agree with you
it's the opposite which is one of your
main talents we've gotten away from that
and it's killing us especially in a
democracy especially in America you
can't my father did a debate tour with n
Gingrich
and you know my father May rest in peace
you know he would you know of course
look NS had his issues in life and
everybody does but they did not agree um
but he respected where n was coming from
on his positions and why he understood
the Dynamics the way he did and they
would have arguments and they would
argue and it would get hot because they
were disagreeing about things that both
people uh believed if the outcome goes
the way you go this is a problem for
something I care about but it wasn't
you're a bad guy it's that's a bad idea
um and like it's like a bad idea being a
Jets fan these days pretty bad idea
there Chris always unless you are a
self- Loa who is addicted to grievance
and then you're going to be jet that's
why they have any Jets fans at all but
look that's why I think you're so
successful one you are uh one of the few
brand guys who's opened people who are
off brand uh which is you know unusual
in the space but I also think it's the
future of the space and you respect the
disagreement which is the ultimate sign
of strength what do you know in any
situation when you're going at somebody
about anything when they switch from
that thing to you oh well Pat you know
you're you're a idiot for saying
that okay the debate's over you know you
you no longer have anything to say to me
yeah so I am now your problem you know
to your point is Trump the problem no no
he is not the problem uh is he
harnessing the problem yes that's a
matter of opinion now you have your
argument that's great um we're not a
trump away we're not an anti-trump away
from being in a better place we got way
deeper concerns that's true um but I
think that this is the success and I am
always a call away why because I believe
in you you're quality guy I know you'd
be a call away from me doesn't matter
what you like and what you disagree with
on this level you know you see something
with me and my son and you're like oh
man I I don't know why you're allowing
that that matters let's talk about it I
respect you as a father I like I like
the way you know your son dropped off my
wife and one of my kids right at at the
airport and then we went with you and
Dylan and Dylan wanted to be around you
yeah no I I just the way you made him
wait and the the I I pay attention to
all of that stuff family stuff is very
important to me again this whole thing
when I message you I'm like I got a lot
of respect for your father I got a lot
of respect for your father and I want to
get to know the family a little bit more
and then it let into the relationship
that we you would have loved him I think
I would have you would you would have
loved him uh you would have been like
Mario you can't believe that these
policies are going to get you to this
place and he would say they are the only
policies that can get us to this place
they are the only policies that ever
have and you'd be like no this didn't
work here this didn't work there and he
would say yeah but here's why and here's
why and we should have done it this way
and should have been that way when is
his birthday and you would have done it
uh forever June 1932 June what month
what 15th interesting okay well gang uh
uh uh one thing for you guys to be
thinking about if you're going to be in
Art Basel next week let us know we may
have something going on at the Soho
House rooftop uh it is By Invitation
Only but do message us to find out who
you are what you're doing what your
background is we may do something
together and Vinnie's got something he's
about to release outside from going to
the bathroom Chris you saw before we wed
and I interviewed none other cuz we met
Bill Clinton in New York he got me a sit
down with Hillary Clinton it's it just
went live a little while ago Rob could
you put the link if you guys want to see
a like she like she reveals a lot it's a
very very very good interview just click
on the link you don't believe that you
were conflicted out of that interview
because of your relationship with the uh
former secretary I I mean I guess people
are going to have to watch the inter
they're going to have to they're going
to have to watch but I mean we go back
like Chris a lot of pain I there's a lot
of memory and emotional pain that I
think you probably should have disclosed
before letting people think you were
going to be a fair broker sitting across
real this too much this is too real by
the way I know click on a link wait till
you watch it tell me I'm wrong after you
watch it you don't feel betrayed have a
great weekend bye-bye
bye-bye